Well,
I grew up base that came to get down.
I'm not internationally known,
but I'm known to rock a microphone.
Oh,
it's crisp and clean.
No Caffeine.
That's better than the other brands I have seen.
It's not a different color.
And I called the rest the radish and that seven up which Wilson's,
that third grade is that a real friends from third grade for a walk in the
garden and do some call.
Pretty Shitty.
Let's start on that.
I don't mind if you tell me.
Just stop following me.
I'm trying to smell you.
Go small for yourself.
This is all secondhand smoke.
You talk too loud in the movies.
Would you please get a little bit to consider,
but did you found a bit too much to think things on the planning cause you got
weapons into any dirty dishes in the sink.
[inaudible]
this lead to more cockroaches.
You need fumigation some hot go with them and stuff and castigation that.
Don't say it man.
Just do what?
I want a curl up in this fluid
and the please.
Could you please be a little bit considerate you in the movies?
We could please get up in the concert.
You too loud in the movies,
particularly [inaudible] you talk too loud in the movies,
which are please give a little bit to consider,
but stop,
look,
look again.
Someone was looking at me.
Cool.
Oddballs and certain little something might go,
Bro.
Let it,
let it,
don't forget it.
Like,
mom,
I need a towel.
Influence.
Use New towels.
So it was Tillery here.
Bad Flavor for the fuck has started.
I gotta hit add flavor in the house.
Ladies and gentlemen,
how are you guys doing?
All right.
This is,
uh,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast with Brian Ryko,
Aka red band with our special guest,
Joe Coco Diaz,
Aka mad flavor eight times a day.
Planet Rock,
Aka Joey Karate sponsored as always by the flashlight.
I don't know why I have to hold this up to the microphone or to them because a
lot of people have seen it for the first time right now.
Oh,
okay.
I do every time though.
I don't know why I do it.
I just keep holding it up.
Most of the people probably listen on iTunes anywhere,
right?
But,
um,
or the Zune,
I don't want to be a Microsoft racist.
Right?
Yeah,
totally.
Is there some something you hear in the background?
Is that like,
oh that's a song part.
Sorry.
It's uh,
the show.
Um,
anyway.
fleshlight.com if you go to my website,
Joe rogan.net,
there's a a link and if you order this,
it gives you 15% off coupon code.
Really good if you fuck it.
And one of the thing,
just a little shout out,
cause when I spoke to one of the owners,
Chris,
he said they were going to come up with some new ideas.
You know like when you buy a box of Campbell soup and shit on the side of it.
Yeah.
It gives you the directions for Campbell soup,
but it also gives you directions for other things you could do.
And I was thinking about other things you could do.
Like you could this out and put ice cubes in there and fuck it.
You follow me?
A lot of people having an invented that yet the ice cubes,
ice cubes.
I wouldn't do it.
But I know for some people you put ice cubes in.
It's like a fucking trick.
We put some ice cubes,
you shake it up and you fucking dry eyes or green tea,
heated.
You know what I'm saying?
Cause it feels nice on your Dick.
Or let's say you had a rough night the night before your bank,
18 hawkers and you fucking Dick is bleeding.
You put Epsom salt in there with warm water and you fuck the ups and saw just a
couple of different recipes.
We have fear at Joe Rogan experience.
Not that I would try this shit,
but I know a lot of you fucking freaks would try this stuff at home.
I know red band would definitely try it.
So try ice cubes that would make it shrink and be sad.
But whatever the fuck.
Maybe somebody stepped on your Dick and ultimate may contest wouldn't dry ice
burn your Dick.
Well that's some people like that Shit took 20 years ago I went to a club to get
quite loose and I walked in,
I'll never forget,
there's like a,
it was called Ramrod.
It was a gay bar in the city and we were kids.
We were like 18 that's the first time I seen a dude with a Cape on.
I thought it was the coolest fucking thing in the world.
A man had a cape on and I walked into this club and before we walked in,
there was a fetish club on the side.
There was a guy in a tub that had a sign on them that said spit on me.
That was his fetish for people to spin on.
So here's the beauty.
I'm standing there.
You know your jaw is gone.
You're drinking.
You Know You had to pee.
And Austin,
they see 20 guys standing on a line for the fucking bathroom.
And I asked him,
I go,
listen,
why don't you just ask the guy in the Tub if we could pee on?
So I walked over to the guy who,
can I ask you a question?
Do you mind if we pray on you?
The guys go right ahead.
There was a point in the night I looked at him,
he had a circle of guys just,
you know all those guys that don't want to wait online,
like Fuck It,
just pee on him.
When I left,
the guy had three inches of p and the fucking tub,
the sign was all fucking melted,
like the black ink when,
but nothing.
It was this guy wanted people to spit on them.
We ended up pissing on it and I pissed on and I'm guilty of,
I don't give a fuck and suck my Dick Allen.
I would piss on anybody.
I don't give a fuck.
He seems like the luckiest man alive.
Oh please.
But that's a crazy as fetish.
But you never know.
Some people's chicken is in the men's Gumbo.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't like pissing on myself.
But this guy wanted you to business spit on him.
Wow.
What is that?
That's crazy shit.
That's crazy shit that when I was in Seattle on Wednesday night at the comedy
club that had a fetish club afterwards,
and there's a couple of times I stayed people fucking crazy.
It ain't my bag of tricks.
You know,
people crazy,
but like clips on their nipples and all that.
I'm not into that fucking shit.
But some,
some people like where's all that shit coming from?
Once all that come from,
I don't know.
The same people who are in hoarders.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what these people fucking comes.
It's just a broken brain.
Like someone who just wants to shock the shit out of everybody.
I don't know.
Like sometimes you're sitting there going,
wow,
I need some action in my sex life.
Fucking people in the ass just ain't enough no more.
I just want to go around and have people piss all over them.
Yeah.
Like,
well that shit or,
or compliment me.
Fuck man.
I like my boy.
It's wasn't really the guy that wasn't what the guys' intentions with the guy.
Just wanted people to spit on him.
Wow.
I just took it to the next level because I'm crafty like about dudes who like
girls to beat the fuck out.
Yeah.
There's people
who are into a lot of them.
A lot of them do to like girls to have beat the shit out of him,
kick them in the balls,
punched them in the faced.
It's fucking,
there's so many videos online dudes love that.
Go for until like the third smack they'll have lose my mind.
Fucking punch you right in the throat.
What are you fucking kidding me?
That's a weird instinct.
Fight with checks and smack them around or for them to smack the fuck out of
you.
Yeah,
but what are you gonna do with people that are animals on a low fee?
You know,
there's people that only fight with their spouses.
They don't fight with other people.
They just fight with their spouses,
you know,
with everybody else.
They like resolve arguments with their spouses.
They beat the fuck out of each other.
Yeah.
Sorry,
I was doing some business.
What were you doing?
Oh God.
Plug this list on the laptop or coming out of the left speaker.
So now it's coming out there.
Right?
But only for extreme.
Oh,
sorry.
Fucking tech tar used to use trim.
You'd been having a successful podcast lately.
How's it going?
Very good,
sir.
What do you guys,
what the fuck you,
I'm gonna say it's funny man.
Very good sir.
Just the way you say and what do want we miss?
Say,
what do you guys talk about?
Like what's the whole,
what kinds of Joe Diaz
podcasts?
It's with Felicia Michael.
He should Michael who is a hilarious comedian.
Um,
and uh,
it's called beauty.
The Bob Cousy of the,
of the thing.
She controls the fucking thing because she's nice and white.
You know the Celtics are one in the 50s.
They had four fucking black guys jumping up and down.
But the guy who was there,
hang wrangler was a whatever the guy just said,
the little Bob Cousy was the white point guard.
He was five foot five.
You wouldn't listen to him,
but he fucking control.
You know,
he pulled the reigns in.
You know what I'm saying?
So she's like the brain puller and I go fucking nuts.
I know so little about sports.
No,
no,
we don't talk about sports.
I'm not,
I mean,
no.
Say it's just the,
it's just that,
you know,
I just used it now.
Should know.
No,
you don't have to.
you wouldn't even fucking boring.
I just used the wild analogy about it.
You know what I'm saying?
What's up red bed?
You're all fucking sponsor of.
There's a fucking big group of people that don't get into any sports at all.
No sports,
no nothing.
And when you talk to them about,
they're just like,
oh no,
I'm not really
separate the UFC,
I'm that person.
You know
more than surprised at how many people are just like that.
How many people don't like going to sports,
but this,
there's people that you would never expect that were like big UFC fans like
that.
I would think it would be like,
like above this,
right?
Like Mike Judge,
the guy who created Beavis and butthead and you know the,
the,
the Fox show,
what does that Fox animated show,
King of the hill and you know,
and so many fucking movies.
He's a huge fan.
I hung out with him in Austin when,
yeah,
well I met him before too.
Yeah.
Met him a long time ago.
News radio.
He was hanging out with Paul Simms and they were playing instruments together.
And this is when I was in full Mike,
Judge Man Lust,
because this is when he had,
uh,
done Beavis and butthead.
Right.
So I was a full on fan boy,
you know,
I was like,
Oh man,
it's fucking Mike Judd cause Beavis and butthead.
To me it was the funniest cartoon of all time.
Totally the funniest handmade show corn.
Julio Dude,
I remember crying,
laughing,
laughing so hard.
I couldn't breathe,
watch my show.
And I didn't even smoke pot back then.
Wow.
I didn't eve.
That was both part about beavers and Bob get really stoned and watching Beavis
and butthead.
Dude,
I got a,
I did something for whoever did Beavis and butthead,
something for MTV.
And they hooked me up with every episode ever on VHS.
They gave me boxes of them and me and this chick that I was dating,
this is when I first moved here and me and this chick droves dating,
just sat in front of the TV all day.
We ordered pizza.
I didn't even know a couch.
And we watch these episodes every episode of Beavis and butthead crying,
laughing.
Wow.
So hanging out with him.
I was like,
this guy likes the UFC.
Like I would thought,
I would have thought you had been above that,
sir.
I can't believe you haven't seen mediocracy yet.
Have you?
Idiocracy no,
no.
You got,
if you're a fan of him and your theories and how you think the rural it is and
stuff,
it combined those two.
It's that movie.
Yeah.
Everybody told me.
Well I,
a lot of people actually accused me of stealing my bit about a dumb people
appearing smart people.
But luckily I had it on DVD before that movie came out and then one could say
idiocracy come on about four years ago,
but I think like three years ago,
it's the,
it caters pick world.
Yeah.
And it came,
it went right to video.
I believe.
I read for that look,
it's a,
the,
you know,
the theory that people are dumb.
People were out breeding smart people.
It's not just mine,
but wasn't it just,
was that that move where they want it mixed races?
No,
no,
no.
It's a movie we're dumb.
People take over.
It's eventually there's no smart people left,
which is basically just like my bit,
but then you know,
everybody sees that everybody's,
you know,
that's the number one concern that an intelligent person has is that public.
How many dumb people are having kids?
Look how many dumb people are in your school system,
clogging up the system with their fucking kids that are already predestined for
retardation.
Just by the way you've raised them,
you've just fucked her.
Head's up.
What they're exposed to.
Also,
because lately I've been watching a little bit more television just so I could
be in the fucking loop instead of criticizing.
I've been watching more television.
It's fucking scary,
guys.
I'll be TV.
I've been watching the Kardashians like for the first time.
I didn't know who these people were and I wanted to see what this is about.
That is the goofiest fucking show ever.
Yeah,
it's ridiculous.
There was some shows out there,
but I'll tell you what shows kicking that hoarders.
How can you let yourself go there?
I know.
It's sad.
It makes me sad about the Kardashians show is Bruce Jenner.
Bruce Jenner was a mother fucker,
Bro.
The fuck is motherfucker.
He was a fucking,
one of the greatest Olympians ever do decathlon.
Is that what he did with the fuck did he do,
he can speak.
He shaking the fucking super.
Absolutely.
Super athletes through super athlete.
Bad mother.
He just got caught up.
He got the plastic surgery.
I mean I don't,
that's just,
how can one deteriorate to that point?
We body nobility.
He's a young kid shooting us fucking
botox shit where we're talking about there.
Could that girl Heidi,
Heidi Montauk.
Yeah.
That's what we do.
We talk about her Warren.
I know we're talking about it cause she apparently is friends with Brian's
friend Esther [inaudible] podcast together.
Her sisters UFC Ringo for awhile.
Uh,
for no Heidi Hollywood.
No,
no,
no.
That's good.
The other one hills.
Yeah.
You're talking about the one that's in playboy.
I don't know these people.
I tried the one that was on that show.
The girls next door I went to,
I went to a party the other day.
I don't think.
We didn't talk about this.
How,
how crazy have you ever been to a crazy Hollywood party?
Like you know,
just,
you know,
thousands of thousands of dollars were spent on a party.
I was at a party the other day that there was baby tigers.
That's how crazy.
It was.
Like burlesque dancers or the biggest Sushi bar you'll ever see and baby tigers
walking around and I was like,
that's ridiculous.
And then you walk out and it's like,
oh,
there's Nikki Hilton.
I guess if you're going to have a party and Nicky Hilton's come coming to a
party,
you have to get baby tigers or she will be pissed off or something.
You know,
because these girls have this fame now where like the Kardashians and stuff like
that where they go to parties and they expect certain things.
Parties are weird,
man.
Parties are weird.
When you're going to basically a club that is someone's house,
I mean that's what parties are.
Yeah,
your house bring your friends and it turns to this gigantic conversation pit of
people.
Those are so strange,
man.
When you don't know people,
you don't know who's there and you're,
there's 102 hundred people in your house.
I mean,
how many parties you've been over like that?
That was,
I've been to like to like,
like the South Park guys had a party once where everyone was dressed like Moulin
Rouge and they were like,
everyone spent like $400 per costume.
At least kind of party.
It was cool.
You walked in and it was like,
it looked like a circus.
That was the first one I went to it.
And the second one was this one.
The last one I went to was they had staff that was trying to keep people out of
the rest of the house.
They would have staff that would like stand there with their hands behind their
back.
So you couldn't go upstairs,
you couldn't go rummaging through,
you know,
the bedrooms and shit.
But they have like a living room area where you're allowed to go to and then
some big crazy ass backyard and just some nutty,
rich motherfucker that just wants to have a bunch of people over his house.
I hate fucking dancers on Poles.
You know that I hate fucked.
They're very strange,
man.
I was a kid.
I'd never really been there.
Very strange.
I don't like people in my house either.
For a party.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Every time the door opens,
everyone's head turned towards the door like who's coming?
Who's it gonna be?
Oh,
it's Ah,
Shit.
I saw her and then magazine.
She looks fat in person.
Oh my goodness.
She's had some work done.
Well,
a party here at the party where these people are gonna Watch you guys go to a
part of this normal.
Somebody puked,
somebody catches a beat,
a purse gets robbed.
That's a fucking party.
When you go to these parties here with these worthless motherfuckers and they're
all walking around thinking that,
and it's fucking amazing.
It's amazing that people stand in line for hours to go into a club.
These are the things that take me and I get baffled by it.
Like I would wait fucking
10 minutes to eat dinner.
Never mind.
Stand that again on a fucking club.
By the time I'm standing there.
He asked if kicked in.
I wouldn't waste my time if I'm not walking in.
I don't want to be there,
man.
That's a strange thing.
Yet that shit with big ass lines that VIP tables and and whatever.
When I was a kid,
you did coke in the bathroom.
That was the fucking VIP.
All right?
That was VIP.
Now you've got to have a VIP table.
It's 1500 just to sit and you gotta be behind the velvet ropes.
100 for a per bottle.
What if I fucking want water?
Listen man,
if you want to live like you're at an art Kelly video.
Oh fuck rules.
There's no rules.
I was once in one of those
lines,
whereas with two girls and we waited in line like an hour and again,
this club and then they get to,
I get to the front and they go,
the two girls can come.
You have to wait.
And I waited for another half hour until I get in.
I get in and then they're like,
the girls are already with gun.
No,
no.
The girls were like,
this place sucks.
Let's go.
And I'm like,
Oh,
where was this?
Uh,
I don't remember.
Miscellaneous Hollywood bar.
Wow.
Fucking crazy.
That's brutal.
That was brutal.
There's this one
please.
Uh,
in Hollywood.
That's cool.
It's like a bondage type.
A dance club.
You walk in there is net above the bar where people,
naked girls are just climbing above you,
so you're drinking and looking up and there's just like Spiderman on top of you.
It's crazy.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
We're weird fucking parties like that,
man.
There's,
that's like a big social thing.
Like who could put on the craziest one?
Who could have a,
you know baby tigers,
right?
You know what?
I want to just set poles and ice cube that melts the fuck.
Is that like an ice sculpture?
Like once the ice sculptures done it apart?
What are you fucking in?
The party's over.
What I say it's fine.
Qualities over with fucking popping does his last fucking line.
That's what it's fucking ice sculpture.
Fucking kidding me.
Oh please.
Beautiful Swan ice at angels.
It's amazing what they've done.
Just like life.
It's amazing what they've done to parties and what people think of parties
should be and how they stand on line and you wait an hour.
So you go to a party for four hours.
You may be,
if you're a regular person and get full fucking drinks at the bar,
by the time the bartender comes to you and you give a,
it's amazing and you're going to go do all this shit tick.
I've told the story about the very first big party that I ever went to.
I was in high school.
I think I've told this story before.
I buy,
I don't remember,
it was a big brawl broke out.
I was with my pal Jimmy Wallace,
who's solely on the message board and uh,
me and him and this kid John Batter,
Rocco.
We went to this part of this Iranian kid through this Iranian kid had just moved
into town.
His family was very,
very wealthy and he just wanted to make some friends.
So he decided he was going to throw a party because his parents weren't home.
Well this kid was like,
you know,
like 1415 years old or something.
So he throws this fucking party and has like five different high schools.
They're like the entire class,
like seniors,
juniors,
everyone's under age.
Everyone's
drinking.
The place is mobbed and people are stealing shit left and right.
All right,
so this place is flooded with horny drunk teenagers.
That's a mansion.
It's a mansion in like this MP,
credible old Boston neighborhood with this giant lawn.
I mean,
it is a huge fucking place and right in the middle of this,
this party,
these kids are drunk and one check says something fucked up to some dude and the
dude says something fucked up to her.
I don't remember what the words were,
but I remember something she did to him.
She either smacked him or she threw a drink in his face.
I forgotten because the right hand and he hit her with is embedded in my brain.
There's no room for anything else.
The student who had a punch and whatever she did to him,
I think she hit him.
Maybe she hit him.
He fucking uncorked one on our face.
I've never seen a dude knock a checkout like this before.
He knocked the checkout like she was at [inaudible] boom.
Just connected on her face.
We'd like this perfect punch and her arms went out.
Her body drops.
You went totally unconscious.
This dude caught her as she went unconscious and then it was on,
it was just on,
it was tables were flying,
glass was breaking.
People were dive in onto piles of people and it was like a fucking movie.
I was like covering my use and sneaking my way through the house,
Bro.
It was a brawls everywhere you looked,
it's like that one punch lit a fire that these kids were just looking for a
reason to fight and people started screaming at people and then piling on top of
people and girls were fucking hitting people with their shoes and people were
diving off piles.
Other pilots of fucking party Jack,
Ooh,
I got outside.
My friends were all cut up and shit.
They're like,
let's get the fuck outta here.
They had just gotten through a pile,
you know,
like dudes were just piling onto each other duties,
just fighting.
It became like,
like they got infected with that rage shit from 28 days later.
Wow.
What's this?
Oh probably like that.
It's tough to stay on the line for a fucking hour to stealing VCRs.
And we saw people walking out with shit.
We saw them walking out with shit.
They just robbed this dude.
Crazy new nobody.
He just moved there.
It was nuts.
Wow.
It was not,
and I'm just,
I've just thankful that nobody fucking jumped on me.
That's all it was.
I mean,
easily,
I could have been at the bottom one of those piles.
There was no logic to those piles.
Those piles were just wild.
Chimp add alcohol.
Who's this fucking prick is fucking prick from Newton north thinks is going to
come down here.
We won shit here.
You know at the scariest thing about that whole thing is zero cell phones.
So that was like
10 minutes to get your fucking car and nobody took a picture of your license
plate.
Hit somebody with a chair,
get eight minutes to get the fuck bad time is back down.
When someone stole your car,
they stole your car.
Let's say that Shit's gone,
son.
There's no internet.
You can't put the license plate online.
Mobile need to find my car.
Take Your Shit,
man.
One of the biggest lessons I ever learned,
I never drank again on new years.
Never
after I seen that one new years,
I went to a party like that.
It was very chill.
Everybody was having a good time and also on one of my buddies couldn't drink.
He started drinking and he started spitting on the floor.
Oh No.
The people,
that person said something to him and he,
he put like 200 hours in.
The person said sometimes.
It was like,
really?
He goes,
he'll,
I'd take my money and leave or I'll fucking,
cause we started some shit and next thing you know,
I'll fight broke out.
That's the first time.
Fuck Mike Tyson,
the Neb on cooler a bit.
My friend's ear off that night,
we had a drive to the hospital.
It was a Baggie with icing and the bottom of his liberal ear lobe was in the
thing and he kept holding on to the car saying as soon as I get stitched up,
I'm going to go back there and fuck him up.
And was one of those times the kid been a movie,
it was hanging.
He's got his ear and a baggy with ice and he's like,
I hope this fucking doctor hurries up cause I'm going to go back to his house
and knocked the fuck out of him.
He's just beats you up 10 times to stop you.
The tech time,
he bit your fucking ear cause you couldn't take it no more.
He didn't know what else to tell the fucking kid.
But I remember that I never drank.
I do years again.
I was like,
I never want to be in that position.
There's some dudes that just don't give up.
No,
he this motherfucker til this day won't give up.
You have to kill him with a stick.
But he was,
he was covered in blood.
They broke them up and he would say,
okay,
I'm already wipe his lip.
He'd wipe his face.
They say go over and shake daddy's hand.
He'd go to the dentist,
said,
Danny,
I'm sorry but your mother's still occur.
Let's go one more fucking time.
And then they do it again for 20 minutes.
The fuck I don't remember again.
All right,
get me low rate and I'll stop.
Danny would go,
you going to stop this time here,
break it up.
Towels,
ice massages.
You know a stitch with Devita and while stitches showing them up here,
let me go shake his hand bro.
Yeah,
it's over.
You know what?
Your mother's still has vd and ass off Jesus fucking Christ.
He just beat you up 10 fucking times and that's how bad it was.
And I never ever,
ever drag again on new years dog.
That's an east coast thing.
Yeah,
that's what some east coast I've ever taken.
Marsha,
no jeans and his parents were like,
where were his friends?
And we're like,
AH,
look at our shirt to cover with fucking blood.
You know what I'm saying?
Like we were holding onto him for dear life and you got people with their kids
is just like having a pit bull that gets to leave the house and go wherever the
fuck it wants.
Right.
You know,
and some people,
you know there's some people that have some crazy fucking kids.
Could you imagine if you had a crazy kid where every time we used to live
leaving the house,
you knew he was gonna come home covered in blood.
His knuckles all fucked up screaming and yelling at three o'clock in the
morning.
I just have a feeling that if that was the happened to me,
like if it got really bad that I would be like,
all right,
I'm taking you to the orphanage or whatever.
Like I feel like I would give up if the kid was like this little redhead kid
getting in fights every day and you say that man,
Shit,
I want to sit anymore.
I'm going to Canada and doing crack.
You have to be a real piece of shit.
I give you a kid up.
People love their kids up.
They keep trying,
but that's what I'm scared of us.
I feel
like I would do that and that's excitement.
Your kid fucking getting in trouble.
Why that's exciting.
Your kid having some fucking drama.
Kind of let me ask you something.
You want to have a fag fucking kid that what you want.
You want your kid to really,
you want your kid to have some fucking opinion even though an early age and to
his,
for him to have some,
some opinion,
there's gotta be some problems somewhere along the line guy.
Yeah,
that's true.
You had your own fucking opinions at eight and nine.
I know you and so I don't know about fucking you,
but I know I did.
I told people what the fuck was on my mind.
I know you did.
You grew up by yourself.
You want your kids that I'd see these kids listen.
Before I was driving,
I seen this kid,
Jewish kid with a Yamaka on walking around like a fucking Momo with sandals on.
I almost pulled over and grabbing him by the shirt and said,
you're a fucking Jew.
Act like it.
You're dumb.
Fuck walking around like some fucking dumpy won't be dude.
I seen [inaudible] fucking kids to the roads.
You Act like you're,
it's like a fucking jubilot mud.
Somebody wants so shoes or something around like a fucking monkey.
Dumpy and not that's a monkey.
But I'll stop fucking book with little sandals on.
Look at these fucking kids.
You want half of these kids to be your fucking kids?
What are you about this fucking shit.
I'm just saying it's not what they dress like,
but you know this kid's a fucking loop walking around and I'm looking to tell by
bodies have racist milk.
No,
I think to milk like he's a fucking moron.
What the fuck?
Fuck Jesus fucking Christ.
Why would I know
these fucking kids around your texting all fucking day and drinking energy
drinks.
You need these fucking kids.
These kids can't even work.
They're so fucking worthless.
You want this shit in your life.
You want your kid to have a little opinion and to stick up from,
so you want your fucking principal to call home and say,
hey man,
you teach it.
Your kid suspended.
Cause he told the teacher he didn't believe that or he didn't believe what he
was saying or something.
And then you talk to them and you level them out,
but you don't want half these fucking kids who the sheet?
The fucking nukes.
I don't want no fucking kid.
That's a half a sheep.
I understand that.
Well what I'm talking about,
it's crazy kids.
You know what kind of crazy kid moboto crazy.
I never grew up with a crazy kid.
Yam.
A fucking crazy kid.
Look at me.
What are you talking about?
What's a crazy kid?
A kid that's going to cause problems all the time.
It's not gonna cause problems like just a minute stints.
The mits causing problems all the time.
It's scary.
It's like shit out my fires.
I didn't do nothing like that.
I didn't mug other kids or or rape little fucking girls.
I was a fucking kid.
I like to have a good time.
Yeah,
me too.
I was an idiot.
I was an idiot when I was a kid.
Why are you an idiot?
Oh,
I used to drive too fast.
I had always had hot rods.
I spun one out in front of the school and smashed it into a tree right in from
the school and broke the car in half.
Life is,
there's no way a 17 year old,
I think I was maybe 16 shouldn't have been able to have a car like that.
What kind of car?
The Jetta?
68 four four two.
Is that a regret of yours?
Uh,
no because everybody lived,
but they didn't have to,
you know that that car?
Yeah.
Oh the car could have hit somebody stuck into the,
to
the car was a piece of shit.
The problem was I didn't know how to drive when it was raining,
when it,
when the car's hydroplane cause it had shitty back tires on it and I hit the gas
and the car just lost it.
It just stuck.
It just spun out and there was no way I can control it.
I didn't know when I was doing,
there was no way I should have had that kind of a car.
The kind of powered those cars have old muscle cars like that for you have young
for that call.
What was the,
what was the first car was a muscle car.
I went straight to muscle cars,
man.
My first car was a 73 Chevelle.
I'm an idiot,
dude.
I didn't want something that gives you economy.
I was,
I had no guidance growing up.
I was pure instincts.
My,
my was like,
what puts the crazy shit I could get?
Fuck yeah.
I want to be like,
hi,
cubic inches.
You know what does it?
It's a 400 to 400 Holly,
eight 50 double pumper.
Holy Shit.
Let's get that.
I wanted to hit blog.
I just wanted hot rods,
man.
That's,
to me it was like there was cars that were like,
just do it.
Get your round,
but they wouldn't do anything for you.
And then there was hot rods.
Like,
why would you have a car that wouldn't do anything for you when you could have a
car that every time you look at it,
you go,
Holy Shit.
You know,
but they're just such a nightmare.
You.
She really shouldn't be allowed to drive one if you're 1617 years old,
that's a death trap is crazy engine in this little retard brain of mine and I'm
16 and I'm allowed to have this fucking metal,
monstrous death machine out there with a bunch of people with their kids out
there walking in the streets and there's no way,
there's no way kids should be able to have that kind of power.
I had in 19 1981 no alliance and my cousin was just going to like donate it to
charity but she,
I bought it off for her for a dollar for I guess for some reason that you can,
you have to have pay something right.
If for some reason,
and it was all beat up and my dad's like this is your first car,
you have to read through this whole entire car to make it look new and stuff
like that.
I'll show you how to do it,
but you have to do all the work.
So like we took like side panels off and I took it,
that putty,
that molding putty and I had to re sculpt this Renault alliance.
You bondo did yeah.
Bonded the whole car.
So we may be like earn it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And so I,
but at the end of it,
it looked like a brand new Renault alliance and it was like,
it was a Renault lines.
I was still funny cause it's like,
and then I went to a station wagon with wood on the sides.
I heard a,
I had a bunch of cars that were like big American muscle cars,
a bunch of them in a row.
And then I got,
I always had,
they were always pieces of shit.
The,
the,
the one that crashed in front of a tree or into the tree rather was the best
one.
That was the nicest one that I had.
They're the ones afterwards were just shitbox of muscle because I was broke.
But uh,
I got an Audi Fox.
Do you know what that is?
Yeah.
It's a little tiny four front wheel drive,
car manual.
It was my first manual and it was my first like really well engineered car and
it was the first car that I drove it.
I was like,
what a piece of shit.
These fucking American cars are God like you don't realize like what a hunk of
Shit,
you know it is to drive a 70 barracuda
like all stock and everything would stock breaks and stock suspension.
Those things are just barely connected to the road there.
Just throw it all over the fucking place.
Taking corners where there was a nightmare,
the steering is numb,
you have no idea where it's going.
And he'd take that and then you go to like a little tiny car that's like well
engineered and handles was like,
wow,
this is amazing difference.
And that car was a piece of Shit,
you know?
But it was still,
it was so much better in.
And then I started to appreciate cars that weren't powerful.
I didn't have to be that powerful to me.
I just realized it was clear.
The Toyota Super I think was my favorite car growing up.
That was fun.
That was my first expensive car.
That got really,
yeah.
When I got on TV,
when I was on news radio,
that was the first expensive car guy.
I got a Toyota supra.
I was like,
Holy Shit,
I have a fucking Toyota supra with the crazy space wing on the back of it.
I heard the bringing it back.
I heard the super coming back.
Really Nice.
I heard that a couple of months ago.
Well,
you know,
they have that Lexus,
if you've never seen it,
that LFA.
They have this new Lexus that's in this incredible piece of engineering.
I mean,
it's like $400,000 and you're not even allowed to buy it apparently.
Um,
what you have to do is you have to lease it and you have to pay the entire lease
portion up front,
and you get it for two years and it's like $260,000 and you have to pay for it
for like two years.
I might in the moment,
my numbers might be off,
but you,
you lease it for two years and then at the end of two years you get an option to
buy it.
It's this fucking insane new Japanese supercar.
It's like 500 plus horsepower.
It's sounds like it's like a super car.
It's like the next generation of car.
How long till apple makes the car that I car?
You know that's on the works?
That's a little table somewhere in some German.
Do think so.
I absolutely think so.
Look at the segway.
Met An apple and mixing in with the car electronics and combining with another
car company to have like just the ultimate car are think they should stick with
the fucking computer and it'd be the gayest thing ever.
It would be like,
what are those things that everyone has now?
I'll hear the hybrids pre areas.
It'd be just like that.
Everyone will have on the same fucking car.
Oh my God.
My first car was a fucking 73 Monte Carlo black on black leather,
500 down to 800 a month.
I got it from the bank.
I drove the cough for two months like a pimp.
I had the electric package with the windows.
I had the roof and one day in the middle of winter,
I went over to the city to get some weed and I went and I was smoking,
so I put the sun roof up.
I lost on the sun,
roof,
went back and the window started going up and down like the electrical system
was sizzle.
I told my buddy,
fuck it,
put your thing.
We're out of here.
I swear to God it was in a blizzard.
I went back there three days later,
the call has a foot of snow on it and all the windows one window was shut.
The rest of the window come in like a day later the sun came up.
I went back two days later with a tow truck.
There was nothing,
nothing.
It was the back.
It looked like a fucking chicken.
The day after thanksgiving,
it was just bone.
They took everything.
Joe,
the seats,
the upholstery,
the fucking black around it.
It was just the tires though,
whatever that the axles,
they took everything.
They left the body on bricks.
That was it.
I never heard from the bank.
I never paid it off and never came back and never came back on my credit thing.
It was vanishes.
Poof,
poof.
I've got to pay for that.
I went years later and get credit like is there check bank a fucking America
with nothing,
nothing without puff,
nothing.
How did,
how's that possible?
I fucking asked me.
I left the car there when it was $5 for whatever it is,
$5 in those days,
like all you had to do was go by the George Washington Bridge and under the
bridge you left your caught in with the keys in it would have half a tank of gas
and leave like a nickel bag.
Your car,
you go back there the next day they would be nothing there.
Nothing vanish.
You can get fucking Barney fife on it.
They wouldn't find your car in New York.
They would demolish your car like that.
He did some little shops in New York,
little bodies this and can I say up in Brooklyn,
like rat.
Then you're done.
You could find like a broken down street,
a broken down car,
driving into all these places.
They'll give you a hundred cash and 24 guests and you'll never see that cog and
dog.
Anybody involved in a junkyard in the junkyard.
The guys involved in the junkyard.
That dude knows how to get rid of looking for too.
I just want something antibody.
I just watched something on CNBC about how big the air bag business was five
years ago before they put the numbers on it.
You have no idea.
People would just steer.
Oh my God.
People stealing their bags like it was going out of style.
I mean just taking your air bags and they didn't work a lot of money.
You 1500 a pot,
so I give it to you.
You saw 15 1500 you rob them,
you take it to a guy,
he gives you three at least sons,
they're 1500 wow.
And everybody's in on the scan because nobody wanted to pay 2,500 wow.
So a guy could steal,
want it sound for 15 was stealing 20 a day.
Oh my 1500 holy shit dude.
CSM,
who's doing that?
Some dude who's making $30,000 that's who's doing all the guy had incredible
guy,
had a ring airbag.
It got so big that he had to get an office and eventually got pot because it was
so big.
He was sending them out across the country.
He went on lunch,
he went on fucking line ed bags for sale next day,
delivery air.
This guy was through,
so you'd say,
no,
my leave,
whatever car you have,
I want a 2010 had back for call given your order.
By the next day he'd send out a robber to go steal it and send you the airbags
overnight.
It was a fucking CSM.
BC.
A one hour special on how bad this,
what's craziness?
Fucking air bags.
How did he think he was not going to get caught if you had a bus?
People working for him.
Yeah,
you'd have to do that Ninja style,
you know would have to only be you.
That's a business where you can't have too much growth.
If you want to go run around stealing,
you've gotta be the one who understands where steel when to do it.
How the alarm word is dealer.
He had first of course not.
Why would it work for him?
Why would they work for you?
The other ones are going to get arrested down Bob Day and waited for him to say,
here,
go get a 68 Chevelle here.
Go get a bread Holt here you'll get an 89 Subaru.
And they just drive around until they find it.
There it is.
They fund now you'll even have to leave like a color.
So do,
did they do it at night?
Everything at night?
I don't know.
Fucking say it really,
but it's just amazing that,
you know,
even if you go over to that,
who are we?
You know,
uh,
Iraq and I ran years ago.
They found that when they went over there that all the cars they would drive
with stolen cars and the states.
Wow.
That they would just sending the whole cars over there.
So when cars get robbed here and we're like,
it's in Mexico.
No it's not.
It's a cab and fucking I route that's could I ran and to don and all those
control,
that's where the stolen cars from here going to fuck.
Wow.
You know,
it's amazing.
And everybody's in on it.
And here we're thinking like,
oh my fucking car got robbed.
I left my fucking kids pictures in there,
whatever the fuck.
And that's what they do with your shit.
You know,
it's,
it's fucking amazing that uh,
and every,
they come up with a new fucking scam,
whether it's online,
I read something and people doing online,
that's just fucking amazing.
Now the Internet has really destroyed scammers.
Here's a new,
a Facebook scam that I just witnessed last night.
Uh,
people who get hacked accounts on Facebook.
They'll be like,
you'll be on Facebook and selling a little chat will pop up and like,
dude,
check this out.
And it,
they put a link and it goes to like the login page of Facebook again.
And so now they're attacking through chats on Facebook.
Like it looks like they're chatting to you.
So watch out for that one because I,
she,
the person I was with almost dead.
I was like,
no,
wait a second.
Why are you logging back in?
You know?
Whoa.
So watch out for Facebook.
So yeah,
those are tricky man.
What is that a virus?
How do they do that?
Somebody gets hacked and I think it just grows and grows and grows like a virus.
He had like one person got hacked and then those persons friends or websites
like or the websites,
the ones that are trying to set you up like how's it,
how are you getting to that?
What's it's doing is,
yeah,
I don't know.
It's like a collecting information.
I think about people probably because someone told me that sometimes you'll go
to a legit website in a legit website.
We'll have been hacked with this thing.
Right?
I don't know.
I don't think,
I don't think it's sad.
I think it's like almost like a spam bot that somebody puts on Facebook,
like my space used to do.
So they can't do that to your website where you would go to a red band.com and
all of a sudden it would say,
hey,
you know,
login to Facebook or something like that,
that your server got completely overtaken or there's your website coding got
somehow can they,
can't they invent a virus that does that?
Like every time someone wants to click on a link,
it opens up a window.
Ask them to log into something.
Absolutely.
That's where your servers have to have good virus software and detections and
what a tricky world we live in.
I'm petrified of the computer.
Petrified.
Just fucking petrify them.
It was like,
I don't put my name on there,
like this things I want to order and shit.
I just got,
I read about all this stuff on that.
I don't know anything about it,
so it even scares me more.
That even scares to me.
What do you have of you?
What have you have drawings,
writings,
you know,
what do you,
what do you have that's that you would really worried about getting out?
I don't know what it is it a big deal you people make about,
I don't know.
What the fuck did,
he has a lot of videos,
like webcam videos of him just sitting there like recorded dancing.
No,
no.
[inaudible] to you.
What can I get from you?
Nothing.
Writing mostly my writings or you know,
it's just the,
the most uh,
intimate thing on my computer.
I'm going to have to quiet these kids up.
Yes.
Okay.
What are you gonna Strap Jelly.
We'll talk about cats.
We hadn't clocked back in house.
You know what I'm saying?
It's deaf.
Fucking house.
I noticed her house.
What do you want from me?
The misses should have tell the children aren't there.
You know what I'm saying?
We should shut up in here.
People know nothing about kids right away.
He's dropping knowledge.
My fucking kids that said fucking hell.
So old school.
This is that.
We're,
we're over here like bothering them.
This is four o'clock.
I don't know if you look,
this is their fucking time when we were kids at four o'clock.
You come into my house,
I'm going to shut up,
bitch.
I got,
I got pipeline,
I'll stab you.
You know what I'm saying?
They don't.
All I'm saying is don't play in front of my door.
Oh,
they're cute kids.
Let them do what they do.
This they house.
What are you gonna do?
Right.
Brain brains.
So old school or excuse me,
Joey is so old school,
right?
You're so old school like it's like almost like,
like you're,
you,
you have your own defined set of rules and he's still use my space.
Yeah.
Do you still use my space and he pimps my space on Twitter,
Bro.
You got to bring them motherfuckers to you.
You don't say enough is enough.
If you put it up and you've got to have something.
There's nothing wrong with my space and I'm gonna tell you why because in a year
we'll be back.
Yeah.
But you know,
it'll be back.
And then all you momos that got rid of your page and slept all your books.
All you fucking moocs.
Me Tappc I have my friends and that zone.
I've been paying attention all this time.
Why are people getting off his face?
Because he hit Joey.
Here's a perfect example of to get off when you,
you're carrying hardy lost two in a row.
You hang out with him.
You know what I'm saying?
You gotta hang on my school.
Your friends aren't real.
All your friends aren't real.
Those are robots.
What do you think those fucking momos on Facebook are going to hang out with you
and bail you out when you hit somebody with a stick?
I don't think some of your fuck go fuck yourself with your friends.
You just want to get up there and tell people what's happening at Facebook.
There's still people alive and kicking that around.
School pitch.
I still got eight track tape.
They track.
I'll send you a podcast on an eight track and shit.
That's the problem with you fucking kids.
Everything has to be fashionable.
Stop fashionable.
They got to come to your fucking world.
That's what we're serving here.
Sorry about the phone.
That ain't me this time,
this time.
So what I'm saying,
that's what's fashionable anymore.
I've got to have a fucking goatee and shaved my head and have an for form suck
for him to what we do.
That's why we do form spring and that's why people are special.
That's why we're special,
because we're fucking three man.
We've got to
have a voice.
Joey,
you registered to vote in California.
That was fucking hysterical.
You said that somebody called me yesterday from Sacramento here.
People listen,
I've got will total all together bus five felonies.
You know what I'm saying?
Total like altogether and out of 52 states,
I ain't fucking bed these days.
So even if I have one east,
there's 50 that's less than 10% I really moved into,
two of them are questionable.
Right?
So there's 52 54 will that Alaska and Hawaii.
I'm fight.
Yesterday I got a calls are stolen from Sacramento yesterday asking me if I was
interested in working the election for one of those cocktails.
Meg Whitman and went,
oh,
that's hilarious.
Hey,
I don't even know what she is like,
God,
you should say yes,
they're going to buy it.
But they threw me off.
I was stoned and they were asking me a bunch of personal questions.
Like,
what if I'm a Republican?
You know,
I don't even know a fucking,
you say you're Cuban.
I'm Cuban from Miami.
Of course,
some are upon me.
I never went through Miami.
I went around that motherfucker.
Where did you land?
New York City with fucking Jz and the chicken.
It's so close to Miami.
You can claim my God,
I don't want,
it's like if you live,
if you live in San Bernardino,
that shit.
If you lived in San Bernardino and [inaudible] North Carolina and some chick,
those where you're from,
you go la.
Did you ever play stickball?
When you're living in New York,
you take boss and I took everybody.
Did you take the fucking thing off the chair?
You see acting.
Joe's got his chairs that it's on the bottom of your chest.
You take that out,
you unscrew from Your Dad's work bench and you take it to the hardware store for
a quarter.
They take the screw out of it and you take that metal thing and you take a
Crayon,
whatever your color is.
Mine was burgundy red in those days when you melt the Crayon into the middle and
then you go out and play those fucking things on the street in New York where
they have one too.
It's like nine ball.
My ball went up the fucking stick.
So you play that for money.
That's how I made money in the first and second grade.
Why would I be doing with your finger?
I always thought stickball was like baseball,
but you have to have stickball which is automatics.
It's,
you know,
that's a far single.
If I hit your mother's fucking pot roast,
it's a double.
I was,
I was very lucky that there was not a pool hall anywhere near my house when I
was growing up.
Very lucky cause I didn't get into pool till I was 21 years old after I had hurt
my knee.
I tore my ACL and I couldn't do taekwondo for awhile.
I couldn't kick box.
So I needed something to do with my time,
you know,
just something to just for my own,
all I was doing was doing stand up.
So I started doing this.
I started,
I started playing pool.
If I was like seven,
eight years old and I started playing pool,
I would've been fucked.
I have never paid attention in school.
I would've just been obsessed with playing that fucking game out.
I've been like one of those dudes,
like every pool hall you go to,
there's some kid who's just cotton school and he's just sitting around waiting
for somebody to gamble all over the country.
They're just sitting around for it.
You want to play a game?
I wanna play a game.
And it's all just about that,
that,
that's just like how they fulfilled their competitive instincts and desires.
It just get caught up in games and gambling for pool.
And then you ever watched that episode of the twilight zone?
There is a twilight zone where a pool hustler.
Yes.
Played for his soul.
Yeah.
And you know,
and it turned out that,
what was the last episode?
Who was in it?
We talked about this already.
You and I just got Jonathan Winters.
Shot them with this was the devil.
Yeah.
And Jack Klugman was the,
what's the fucking point?
He wanted to be the best and I slow one and this guy was like a dead guy and he
came back to play him right.
And the,
the,
uh,
the thing was he had already lost cause he had,
he had devoted his entire life to just playing pool.
He had wasted his life.
He'd wasted his life playing this game.
So He'd lost anyway.
And it was like,
wow.
It's like you don't realize like [inaudible] there's certain things that you can
get obsessed with and you know,
and it's fun and you enjoy it and you can,
you can have a good time.
You could play golf on the weekends and it can add flavor to your life or you
could just get caught up in it.
And that becomes everything you know,
and gambling when you're a kid,
when you're a young kid,
how many guys,
you know that what you are,
you are kids that all they wanted to do was play cards.
The only wanted to do was find games.
All they wanted to do is gamble.
Go to the track race,
track,
horse track.
Everybody was camp when you're a kid,
fuck yeah.
I didn't live with us.
I really,
one thing I really,
I never told you about that.
My mom had the bar and from the ages of like seven to 10 I was really,
I got hooked on pool,
but it was I,
the reason why I stopped playing full pool was cause I got really creepy.
It overtook me.
Oh yeah.
I asked to get into the pool and I would say things to people about them.
That was creepy.
Like I was always playing and one day I went home and I checked myself.
My mother asked me,
she goes,
what the fuck is that?
Why you just your competitive drive?
It really taught me,
I've ever wanted that feeling ever again.
Like it stopped me from being that competitive.
It's not just balls going into a hole.
There's something about pool.
There's a reason why everybody has this thing about Paul being a manly game.
You know what I'm saying?
Like there's certain games like not who gives a fuck.
If you're good at donkey Kong,
no one's going to be impressed.
But like,
you know what I'm saying?
If a girl beats donkey Kong and what the fuck?
Who Cares?
A girl beat you at pool though.
That's a totally different world.
There's something very manly about being able to control that ball.
Being able to keep your composure,
being able to pocket those difficult shots,
being able to run out.
That's a manly thing.
That's uh,
being able to keep your shit together,
keep everything tightly tuned.
It's almost like are like I'm moving yoga sort of a thing.
I'd be so much more specific.
Girl beat me at donkey Kong.
Really.
This is horrible.
What is happening to me that's just cause you're a super nerd.
Like if a girl beat me a quick,
that would be way worse than this quake,
which would be way worse than pulled from me.
But that quake was,
quake was a bigger obsession.
That pool was because I didn't always have to,
you know,
I couldn't always get people to play me in pool.
Like,
sometimes I'd go to the pool hall and there'd be no one in play.
You know,
you'd have to sit around and wait or you have to practice by yourself and you
know,
and maybe someone will come in and you know,
this guy can't play him to good or you don't,
he won't give up a spot.
Or I'm looking for a new with playing quake.
He just get online anytime you want,
you just hop online and play.
You didn't need to buy it and you call it a duty next week or
whatever.
I'm scared.
I saw this fucking an for the new star wars game,
there was a star wars game and that they showed during the UFC.
It looks so dull for suddenlies too.
Oh my God,
the fucking graphics.
I don't know if this was in game footage or if it's one of those tricky things
where they like pretended sim game footage,
but it's not really,
it's just like some animation about the game that they've created.
Right.
The last one was pretty good,
but that's not my cup of tea too much.
I like the first person shooters more unless they changed that.
I don't,
it's not our first person shooter to third person shooter where it's like from
behind the person.
I don't like those.
Yeah.
Those aren't as fun to me.
I want to see everybody else.
I want to see it as if I'm seeing it.
I don't need to see my character.
That's stupid.
You know?
I might want to see the hand in front of me with the gun.
I kind of liked that look and quake.
Sometimes when you see the hand in front of you with the gun,
I'm like sometimes it's easier to come or something.
It's easier to remember what you have to look.
You don't remember if you have a lightning gun or if you have a real gun or
sometimes I would just have it where I'd only see the cross hair,
but that's the muscle most fun game.
The way.
That's the most fun way to play it to me because it's the most immersive cause.
That's how we see things.
We don't see our body outside our body running around.
That's ridiculous.
It doesn't even feel like me,
but when I'm playing quake and it's just me,
you know there's a cross hair and I'm running down hallways and shit.
It's too exciting.
Can't do it.
Scary to you should do it and now do it in three d.
That's the best.
When I'm at peck playing first person shooters in 3-d on on the TV,
I'm sure it's about the shirt.
Give you like crazy.
I site it would probably be fuck with your eyeballs.
It's,
it's intense though.
You feel way more immersed into it.
A lot of guys,
when they're playing quick,
they kill all the graphics.
They would kill all the graphics and make it look really flat and the,
the idea would be that so that the opponent would show up better and so that
their,
their processor,
their computer,
that looks terrible,
but it's,
they're more in it for the numbers.
They're half the look like the real gun looks like.
You only see like a straight line to it.
There's like a lot of,
a lot of the graphics are gone.
She does claim.
Have you ever played a video game,
Joey?
No,
not even PAC man pac man.
Yes we uh,
pacman frenzy back in the day you were by them.
The other one,
Mrs Pack Miss Bag on anybody who got good at that quake game and started playing
it,
anybody would get hooked.
It is so exciting because it's so three d you know the thing about first person
shooters,
especially ones like quake,
it's like you can do things like you can,
you could run around,
you can jump,
you can,
you can rocket jump,
shoot down at the ground and go flying through the air and land on things.
I mean this is a completely three dimensional world and most of these maps that
you're fighting on,
they have all these levels to them,
layers and levels and you travel back and forth and up and down and you're
running down these corridors.
It's all in real time fighting other people.
So you really need to place a new video cam chat.
I can't get,
cause if you really think that highly of quakes graphics in rural,
it's like four is pretty dope.
Even quick for it.
You take quick for the best machine you can possibly buy.
You take that times that probably by 2 million and then that's where that video
games are nowadays,
which,
which games are really like,
there's just so many like call of duty is one that I personally love that it's
amazing.
I mean it's,
yeah,
it's so realistic.
It's just so immersive at Uw Madison we sorta lands and another one that you
would totally fucking love.
Do you remember when we saw gears of war before it even came out?
Yeah.
Gears of war buddy cliffy be,
uh,
from epic games.
Who's a cool motherfucker.
I get him on.
Yeah.
I would love to have him on the podcast.
He's just one of the nicest guys ever.
And just super cool,
friendly dude.
And we met him,
uh,
and he showed us a bunch of shit.
It was before gears of war ever came out and he was like,
you know,
what did he,
what we're going to,
we're about to fuck doom in the ass,
right?
Cause Yeah.
Cause do three d it just came out and yeah,
I forgot all about that.
Yeah,
I remember that.
And he was showing us the gears of war stuff and we were like,
oh my God.
Yeah.
That was like eight months before that game was even like released or something
like are announced and you don't realize what hard work is until you see game
developers.
You see the amount of hours they put in like Tim Willits from ID software and
Todd Hollingshead and all those guys and John Carmack,
you know,
have I get to hang around with them getting to go to like id software and see
like where they make the game it wanted to,
first of all,
it's so humbling how fucking Badass these guys are.
Like the,
the designs,
all the crazy graphics and all the things that they're constructing.
You know,
I remember we went there to id before doom three came out and they were showing
us like some demo versions of it.
It's just fucking amazing shit.
Just the artwork.
But then you talk to them,
you're like,
like how much time do you guys spend working this?
And they're like,
it's like 16 hour days every day.
You work on Sundays.
They were constantly,
man,
it's in the till to take time off and go on vacation.
It's amazing how much,
like they're kind of like South Park for eight months,
you know?
And then there's like,
even when it comes to everything in Hollywood,
like any kind of CGI or computer graphics,
it seems like they're all like that.
Like I know somebody that's doing Harry Potter Three d right now and it's just
like 19 hour shifts.
Know what's up with that man.
If you had kids and you know,
it's like you motherfuckers need to hire more people.
Like this is ridiculous.
Why is this guy going to work 16 hours?
Don't you guys make like $1 billion a year doing this shit?
I mean,
how many,
how many fucking video games that they make?
You know,
video games make a fuck load of money,
man.
Did you ever play it into plane to new UFC game with you in it?
And I don't know,
fuck around with.
No,
I'm scared.
I told you I'm scared of games man.
I love it cause I don't want to get fucking hooked.
I don't want to have people over come on,
what was supposed to move to and then also than the sun's up and birds are
chirping and I can't believe I'm still awake.
My eyeballs shot and I sleep til three in the afternoon.
Yeah,
I did that.
I did that for years.
I love it because I do it in target.
They have a UFC,
a,
a demo that's constantly playing.
And so I was in target the other day shopping and stunning to hear your voice
like behind me going,
oh no.
Or something like that.
I'm like,
fuck,
isn't that what you'd probably do?
And what we actually did,
um,
we did two things.
We did it.
So I have to go in,
start working on it again.
I'll really,
yeah,
we're working on a new one soon.
They just,
uh,
I think next month I start.
Wow.
But um,
what we do is we play certain clips of fighters,
like doing stuff and you call the action while it's actually happening.
He'd do that.
And then you also like make imaginary scenarios,
like imaginary scenarios.
Like he'll hook transitions to the arm bar and watch how it transitions to the
back and we'll try and come up with a bunch of different possibilities for that.
And then we have descriptions of this fighter taken on this guy and this fight
or take them.
There's like endless combinations.
So there's,
there's uh,
there's so many hours he put into the game.
I mean,
just ridiculous,
stupid hours.
When you guys filmed it,
was there any Easter eggs that you know of where you had like weird scripts that
you wrote that was like,
all right,
why am I doing this?
This is weird.
No,
that's a good question though.
That's a good question because there's a lot of Easter eggs and games,
right?
And Yeah,
there's actually a bunch of games.
There's a list of like the top 10,
I think it was on crack.com of the top 10,
like Easter eggs that were,
it took the longest to find,
like there was one that it was just found the other day from some nes game,
you know,
from,
I don't get Easter eggs,
man,
I don't get it.
If you want to put something on like,
and Eddie Bravo on is a twister.
The DVD to twister.
He had uh,
the Easter egg was Brian Keaulana doing that?
Uh,
Gay Brazilian Jujitsu instructor.
All right.
You don't remember that you've seen that video,
right?
Which is hilarious.
Like,
dude,
why wouldn't you just put that on the day that seems,
yeah.
Easter eggs should be just little things maybe,
but that's only the video.
Why would you hide that somewhere?
Deepen your,
well,
you have to press control,
alt delete to get to it.
Or what do you have to press to get to the east direction?
Musically it's just up arrows.
Like you have to hit the air right down,
you know?
Yeah.
But you have to do it in the right order.
Right?
Like down,
down,
left,
right.
It depends.
Sometimes it's like you fuck you for making me look for shit like that.
Just clicked the flock.
If you've got something,
show me.
Put it out there.
Yeah.
What the fuck man.
You treasure hunt,
all those sorts of treasures out there.
What is this shit?
He's the barracks yourself to your daughters and shit.
So you guys come up with the bosses?
Yeah.
You go out there,
you say you can't talk.
No,
you don't look at you with this motherfucking,
I'll say that.
You look at the wife and he goes,
oh,
okay.
Really?
Are you fucking serious?
She doesn't have had them all.
God Damn.
They run up and down,
run around and target.
They heard your voice yelling and screaming.
I thought it was you there.
What are you nuts?
And look at?
And then I said,
quiet.
So you can't say that until the kids just kind of fuck.
You know,
I told you,
you don't say anything to the kids.
Nothing.
They run the fucking place.
And Joe,
have you ever heard of something called Geo caching?
I think that's what Geo caching?
No,
it's this whole thing and said,
this is one of these weird things that you would never know existed with us.
He just ran across it.
It's like a game that the whole earth or whatever is the,
the playing field and these people,
uh,
put g get gps coordinates to different boxes or treasures throughout the haunt.
Heard about this.
It's so crazy.
So like,
so what it is,
there's maps and there's,
there's websites that you go to that you try to find these little boxes that's
spread out throughout cities everywhere.
And then you get to one of these boxes,
you open it up and I think he signed like your name on it.
And then you look,
sometimes there's little treasures or presence in there and you just,
or you add things to this little box,
like,
you know,
like a cool badge or like a diamond or something.
Not Real diamond,
but whatever,
you know.
And then,
uh,
it's like this whole like game that people play.
It's called Geo caching and there's iPhone apps for it.
There's,
it's,
it's so weird.
I've always wanted to do it,
like at least,
or at least look at a box and see what's inside of it.
You know,
if you weren't worried about people being stalked and you weren't worried about
like nuts on the internet,
you could have a pretty dope TV show or you like give out coordinates.
Right.
You know,
and,
and you know,
you tell this dude where to go and then you're released that information on the
Internet and he's got to go do something that people from the Internet will help
them out.
Right.
But then you,
the problem is you just have some nut who would just be like,
you know,
you will know her brothers in another life.
I have eaten crystals and seen this version,
and then he'd be fucking followed you around everywhere and you could have
issues with that dude,
you know?
And if he knew that he could get on television by helping you and becoming your
friend,
you know,
but you can have a pretty dope TV show like that,
that would be cool.
You'd have to,
you can't,
that's no filter.
I mean,
Internet show,
there's no reason to have TV show.
Oh,
you mean,
yeah,
I guess,
I don't know,
man.
I mean exterior siding,
dude,
TV is still what you're getting from TV,
the,
but there's not,
it's not like there's not going to be TV anymore.
What is this going to be?
Is that Internet and TV sort of merged together?
Yeah.
You know,
because TV is still cool because you've got,
first of all,
you got to experience producers,
people who know how to film things correctly.
People who know how to like write scripts.
You've got like all these talented motherfuckers,
so it's never gonna go away if the shit they're producing is really cool.
It's just somehow or another they're all going to merge together,
but you're not going to get rid of TV.
The idea of like getting rid of TV,
who's going to make lost?
Who's going to make some know what it's going to be though.
It's like,
that's an example.
You've got a Jimmy Kimmel's website you can watch like every single one of his
episodes for way,
way,
way back.
So it's just going to get to a point where they're not broadcasting TV to like,
that's what I want to fucking do is watch Jimmy Kemble.
You know what I'm saying?
Listen,
let's get down and fucking dirty here.
Cocksuckers so like it's going to get to a point where they're just not
broadcasting in any more.
There's no cable companies.
It's just going to be like every show has their own website initially.
Jimmy Kimmel's dot com state of Jimmy Kimmel on channel.
And then there's been going to be people who set up networks online or it's just
like connects online to your television and it's an alternative.
[inaudible] Google TV,
apple TV,
TV show,
Sam.
So,
so right now your website might have some cool youtube videos,
but imagine it in the future being a channel.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Is we always said that that's probably what's going to happen right to it.
Everyone's going to get their own channel.
That websites literally will be like channels and everyone's gonna have their
own little fucking thing.
That's why it's going to be a real problem.
Like I reality show,
like if apple reduces a thing,
produces some new thing where you make your own reality show,
right?
Like it's a fucking hat and you put this hat on TV like a little thing and
there's a camera right in front of you and you just carry it around with you and
it broadcasts wirelessly on the four g network and to Justin TV.
It started off as he did at one guy,
one guy,
24 hours a day he was on TV.
What I'm saying is that
apple would create an APP,
not an APP,
but a a device like a new version of,
you know like they have the iPad,
some new crazy thing and this thing would be I reality show your own reality
show.
It would edit it for you.
You'd be able to do it all with voice commands and shit.
Cut,
edit,
rewind,
delete,
broadcast.
Totally.
Yeah.
It'll show it to you.
A little heads up display right in front of you.
Would you like to send this online right now?
Yes.
Bam.
Do it online.
Right from there.
That's when we're going to have real attention whores.
Who's gonna you know what was going to do the nutty shit on their reality show
to get people to watch them.
Totally.
And there's some people out there that'll become famous that can't get a reality
show right now.
You think,
well,
hey,
you know,
all you have to do,
no days just get a reality show and you're famous.
Yeah,
try getting a reality show shit head.
You think it's that easy?
You gotta be like Kim Kardashian.
You gotta suck some black tick.
You gotta fucking,
you've got to get people interested in you.
You gotta get that white ass naked.
What is one of people?
What are people going to see every week and listen,
she shows that big thick going into a big Dick.
Go in and do a pretty face gobble,
gobble,
gobble.
That chip just went for it.
She just like,
how about this?
Come on seven.
I'm going to be a,
a fake porn star.
I got a plant in porn site with an out,
you know,
you're gonna Watch me.
Fuck.
But it's only because it was an accident.
You know,
it's post to see me.
Fuck.
Should I tie him?
And then she just slings it out there.
All those crazy bitches showing their pussy when they getting out of cars.
I mean,
they just took,
took whoredom to like the next level.
Hopefully when they raised the bar.
That's,
yeah,
that's how hard it is to get a reality show.
You've got to do something like that and you gotta be there.
You gotta be in this,
the soup of Hollywood.
You can't start a reality show like that from Nebraska.
No one's going to give a fuck.
They're just,
it's just not going to happen.
Everybody shot reality shows.
Even octomom now you have to be fucking interesting.
Something has dot.
You have to be interesting.
Now you have to be interesting or crazy.
Could shoot a reality show,
but now you have to be interesting.
Yeah.
You're like I was saying,
I'm watching a couple of shows lately.
I understand that he's fucking people crazy.
Hey,
let me tell you something,
Doug.
I just want to mention one thing that this is the year of the Mexican,
the Miss America Philippe spa is the one in the last comic standing the
dishwasher.
They'll compadre toot you getting off on that one pound of the coke deal with
the racial profiling and now your boy came motherfucking Valasquez on Saturday
night.
It's the year of the Mexican Mexicans are taking over the fucking,
just a matter of time.
So many of them,
it's the year of the fucking Mexican.
But the way he took over was amazing.
I couldn't call that in a million years.
That's why you didn't see Joey karate video cause I really couldn't call that
but was at eastern fuck them up dog.
I would've lost a lot of money at that.
UFC booze and psychological first told me about this.
Well I had heard good things about him.
I had heard like,
this guy's really good.
You know,
this guy is a very talented,
this guy works really hard.
This guy's very dedicated.
But you hear that about a lot of guys.
There's certain guys who stand out.
Cain was always the guy that stood out.
Like you'd remember him.
Like people would talk about him like before,
like when he had like his very first fight in the UFC.
But,
um,
Phil Baroni was to me and
uh,
I think we were in Germany and we were sitting around talking and he was just
going off about how good cane is.
He's like,
he's the real fucking deal.
He's the best in the world.
He goes,
I don't give that up for anybody because I watched him run through guys.
I watch them,
never get tired.
I watched him do these conditioning drills and he's the last one to get tired
when guys like Josh Koscheck and well two words.
And he was like,
you never see that.
You never see a heavyweight that can go at the same pace as welterweights and
beat them in con and conditioning and endurance drills.
He's like,
the God never gets tired.
He goes,
it's incredible.
he would,
you know,
like him and cost check,
you know.
And both of them are incredibly well conditioned and he would like do as much as
cash check or more.
That's insane.
Like you never hear about a 240 pound guy that's able to do that.
You know the hundred 70 pound guys mean that's where the real endurance is.
Now that's where the above hundred 45 pound guys,
some motherfuckers can go,
go figure you go for f Frankie Edgar,
try slow and Frankie Edgar down.
Good luck through Frankie.
Edgar could go for 20 rounds if,
if,
if it was a fucking contest to see like if I get it gets very difficult to
catch.
You might be able to beat him at a decision.
Very difficult to grab a hold of.
Very difficult to catch in this submission.
I mean he's fast,
it's fuck his foot works good as wrestling's good.
If every fight was 25 rounds,
Frankie Edgar might not ever lose ever for the rest of his life until he decides
to retire.
If he just keeps going until one of your breaks to one of your slows down,
it's going to be,
you know a mother fucker.
You just keep going.
There's certain guys that that weight,
but you never hear about that for two 40 except Kane.
Kane's the only guy I've ever heard about that as a heavyweight.
Can you hear things about Brock Lesnar studies freak like that?
His like if you look at like as a numbers,
like his ability to like,
I think,
I don't remember what his combine numbers where I have it on my phone.
Well,
but they're insane that the fuck knocked out of him.
So the combined numbers don't come into it.
No,
but I'm saying is confused about all those numbers.
Go out the fucking window.
Let me tell you something.
You know what,
What Aka seen that I seen the first fight with Shane Carwyn Bro,
that really fucked me up.
That it all comes to you right there.
It all came to me as I was looking at them right before they're getting ready to
go.
I looked at my wife and I go,
Cain Valasquez and knock this mother fuck out.
And I didn't think that two right there,
that's why they didn't do a video.
And I thought about two things.
A lot of people saw that.
I thought that I thought that I seen what Shane did to him and,
and I think that this guy just said,
I'm going to do it.
Shame do with endurance and just get them before the first round.
And then I seen some of the Shane Carla fight that nobody fucking mentioned.
Yeah,
there's one part in the shin color fight when they're getting started where she
ain't call and hits him and after he gets hit he goes,
that mother fucking never been hit before a bitch.
That motherfucker that he thought this was a wrestling game.
He ain't never been hit before.
Did you know that?
I didn't think about that.
Think of an experienced fighter when he gets it,
he'll smile.
He'll go like this.
He went like this,
look at that first fight again when he fought one and that's when I said,
Ooh,
they just,
if Aka scene that they said they seen something,
he don't like getting it.
So I had to fight against somebody posted on the underground.
They could have very well been trolling.
I have no idea.
But they said trolling,
trolling is just,
you post something that's not true to try and get people to bite and that people
start arguing this is bullshit and then you know,
you'll laugh your ass off because he got a bunch of idiots arguing over
nonsense.
Do you know what trawling used to mean by the way?
No.
It used to mean a guy that chased after other men.
Really?
Yeah.
Because,
uh,
when was that online and Meghan in trouble with the animal pet or Los Angeles,
pet police or whatever they're calling.
What you got,
there's pet police and somehow they got in trouble.
Did they call it and you got in trouble with the pedal at all?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Uh,
animal control,
animal control weapon cause people on the Internet like outlaw on all these
people were telling this poor girl in my space that I like tortured cats and
there was something like that.
Oh,
that's right.
Right.
You know,
you had made a fake video or something.
I made a fake video where I had a cat and a fridgerator and I used to,
I just like,
I keep it in the freezer,
stuff like that.
But anyways,
uh,
so they call the animal control at me and I had to explain to this guy that I
was trolling or they were trolling people on the Internet and he goes trolling
in and he's like,
yeah.
And he goes,
well,
what's me?
And I'm like,
you know,
like joking or kidding goes,
oh,
well that meant something out.
Something else went back in my brain.
Oh,
boxy.
Wait before that,
way before that Jeanette.
Yeah.
Talk about,
she was trolling.
Trolling is like a lot of people,
a lot of dudes will pretend to be girls and they'll get dudes to bite.
So the,
you know,
like,
and then they'll get to say some ridiculous shit and then at the end they're
ah,
I'm a dude.
You faggot.
No one's coming to your house to suck your Dick.
You know,
there was a lot of that.
And Doug,
uh,
Stan hope did a whole bunch of trolling against,
with pedophiles.
He would,
uh,
do it.
There was a thing called baiting.org.
I don't know if it's still around.
I think Doug wrote a book about it.
I think he's got a book up upper,
doesn't he?
I,
I think there were doing a book or he has a book,
I'm not sure,
but I know there's a lot of his blogs that are still available.
You can find them online if you just go to Doug's Dan hope.com.
I'm sure everything is there.
But he,
uh,
had this whole thing where he would pretend to be a little kids and he would
troll pedophiles and then we would post it all online.
Like what were they charging about?
Oh,
see that somebody was trolling something about Brock Lesnar.
What they were saying was that,
um,
no one was allowed to punch him in the face during Johnny telling you dog.
That dude has never been lit up all his life.
He's always been the fucking biggest guy.
What about,
so nobody's ever said to him,
come on [inaudible] let's get it on.
Do you think it's possible that um,
all the pro wrestling than he did and you know,
playing football for a little bit that he did too.
Do you think maybe he suffered a bunch of concussions?
No,
Bro.
He don't think so.
Some people had never been hit because they've always intimidated people.
This motherfucker took a tool.
I really don't think he's coming back.
I think his ego got busted up like your boy again.
Trinidad against but not Hopkins.
I don't think so.
He's two ECO Pisco is ego and this confidence.
Well,
you know he came back,
left,
came back and comment on,
I don't know about that because he came back better and stronger after frank
near tapped him.
But that was a leg lock.
That wasn't a punch to the fucking face brow.
True Big fucking difference.
When you get punched in the fucking face twice and when they cut you and you got
to see that every time you shave,
you see that every time.
I don't think he's going to beat that guy.
I think the gap is too big.
When I think about when I,
when I see that guy,
what I see when I see the two of them,
the way they performed when they were fighting each other.
I saw one guy who was like this unbelievably strong,
powerful,
fast guy,
but he didn't know exactly what to do with his body.
He didn't know exactly how to handle situations.
He did know to do the right thing and the other dude who maybe not as strong as
him,
but pretty fucking strong and has real good technique.
Everything he does perfect.
Everything he does is smart.
All his footwork is smart.
He can go at that same pace and keep going.
He's not exploding a shitload of energy that he can't recover from.
He's like,
he pays himself better.
He handled it more professionally.
It's like one guy's a black belt.
I'm looking at a black belt in MMA and came to Alaska.
It's like a master and it,
Brock,
I'm looking at this super powerful purple belt.
You know this,
this just ridiculously powerful guy who could get away with a lot of shit.
If you don't have perfect technique,
you really won't be able to stop them.
But a guy like Cain has perfect technique.
That's the difference.
I think that the next guy they're going to put them up against,
which is what's online is frank man.
No,
no,
no.
Oh,
go Brock.
Saying,
can I tell you what I think Frank Miele,
take it.
Come down because now we all know what to attack straight at them.
Throw a bunch of fucking punches and punch him in the face.
It was when I was a kid.
I grew up in Northbrook and we played all the fucking,
I hate to say this,
we played all of the black schools were group for you play a passe.
You play Paterson,
eastside.
These are fucking schools,
Jack.
You don't go in there and just talk,
hi,
how are you about Chad?
There ain't no chat at these fucking schools.
And the coaches would tell us,
bro,
the first play of the game,
fire out like you fucking assholes on fire.
And then you establish,
then you'll see that they back off a little bit and that's right.
This didn't happen.
Happened.
Brian,
everybody's seen that.
If you're a great fighter,
you seen that car and had them in a way go call cotenancy.
Karlyn had them and the question,
I think that he never been hit.
I think he's never been fucking lit up.
Well he is sparring with people though.
There's video barn they call used to eat broccoli.
I think they just take it easy on them.
I got by Lowe's broken in the sixth grade.
It's still hurts.
It's still fucking hurts.
All right.
It still hurts my nose and I didn't know for years cause I was doing coke for
years.
I thought I was doing coke because I had pain in my heart.
Who I was.
I don't cook from the fucking pain in my nose.
I had my nose busted.
Three you doing?
What are the pain your nose go cause you like coke
police thing over here.
Let me tell you.
So that's the newest,
latest theory.
The last 10 years my fucking nose has been hurting.
I can really,
what is that pain from?
It's from fucking getting your nose broken.
It's doing the sixth grade.
I was never going to be a fucking fighter.
It's totally unrelated to all that coke.
I know there's a joke.
It's a joke.
You fucking mobile.
What I'm saying is go that it's so weird that the last two years my nose is
really been fucking hurt and I never hit it by mistake and nothing lately,
but I remembered when I broke it.
The pain I had that when you fucking break,
let me tell you something.
He got a cut in desire.
He had a bloody nose.
The worst thing about having your nose broken as if you have your nose broken.
Seven out of 10 times they busted your upper lip too.
So you got snotty blood.
You're tasting and salt the blood fucking from your mouth.
You remember that taste for the rest of your fucking life.
I don't give a fuck who you are and that's not a fucking good taste.
That tastes always equivalize as to something that ain't good,
man.
I'd been my,
my nose had been fucking broken jack and I'll tell you what,
it hurts and he got fucking beat up Dni.
He got beat up dog.
I did that last punch when he got it.
He got that on the floor.
I've watched that and 10 times already.
He got it on the fucking floor.
He got hit.
I don't think he's coming back like that.
I think that fuck with him.
He's a big viking ego fucking shit.
Somebody took it to you mother fucker.
It's a different game now.
You get humble and he may come back strong,
but he's going to let people punch them in the fucking phase.
Now watch that car when fight when it's on next time.
Watch it again on your computer and you'll see what I'm talking about.
And nobody mentioned,
nobody mentioned that at all.
He got hit.
One people did mention it.
A lot of people,
he got hit.
He cowered when she fucked,
he went e that means he's never been hit before.
That means Jack.
Um,
I don't know about that man.
Never been.
You know,
it's kind of a,
it's an interesting thing because he was such a huge draw,
you know,
and,
and still is such a huge draw because a pro wrestling and everything like that
that he was like rushed right into the big leagues right away.
Like if really,
if you wanted to be smart with a guy like that and you wanted to really build
them up correctly,
you know,
you wouldn't just do that with them.
You would slowly work them in and then having fight for the title once the
demand was through the fucking roof.
But they just,
they had that perfect fight with him and Randy coture,
it was such a perfect promotional fight,
you know,
one of the greatest ever fucking hall of Famer fighting this new,
big,
young,
crazy dude and holy shit.
Can he beat him or really Randy was,
you know,
I mean he was the heavyweight champion,
but you know,
he was 45 I think at the time.
And it's like,
you know,
it's past his prime to be fighting a guy that's this big and this athletic at
this crazy.
So all the sudden Brock be him and now Brock is just at the top of the heap with
all these for Roche's Lyons who have been doing MMA for 10 years nipping at his
heels.
And so there's a big goddamn gap there.
You know,
there's a few guys there that have a big ass gap.
You know Keynes,
one of them is his full MMA game is at a way higher level.
The time that he's put in the,
the way he picks things up,
he's just,
everything he does is perfect.
He's a baby and each one six or so,
something like that.
Yeah.
Fucking baby is a baby.
So all you heavyweight motherfuckers just by the start dropping that at two oh
five and shit.
Yeah,
it's going to be scary for a while.
Good luck with all that.
I just want to tell people that when I don't make a joy karate videos sometimes
it's like sometimes Eddie's out of time,
but the other times is that I'm fucking stumped and I don't want to give you bad
info.
I was going to go with Brock.
I would've gone with Brock.
I would've gone with Martin Kampmann.
Matt Hamill was the lock of a year.
Let me tell you something.
Anytime Tito fights,
when you better get,
and I love Tito debt.
I was one of his biggest fucking fans,
but every time he fights now,
just bet against them dog.
That's as easy fucking locked right there.
And I hate to say this,
but it's true.
If I had $10,000 I would've bet better on fucking Manhattan.
Well,
that's a no brainer anymore.
Damn stop.
You can always bet Sam style.
I'm not going to sit there and be Houdini.
That was the win rate.
Rock against whatever stem style is always fucking good.
There's a casino that always got a line on sand style.
Those motherfuckers always come down.
Those guys played a wind.
San Stay just don't hit too fucking hard.
It's hard as fuck.
Sam started hits very hard.
He just fighting really good guys,
you know?
I mean not duty fought Paul Taylor,
that goes,
I'm motherfucker,
motherfucker,
motherfucker.
That was a great fight for the kids.
Hear me yelling and screaming.
Yeah,
they can hear you.
That's all right.
It's all right.
I'm sure they've been swept a though it's their uncle Joey.
That's fucking crazy.
That's uncle Joe Kampman shields fight.
Man Catlin could've won that fight.
A lot of people thought that I was hyping up shields and,
and uh,
that I wasn't talking enough about Cameron.
I think,
you know,
I'm a big camp and fancy bullshit.
You and I were talking about camping at dinner Friday night.
I said to you,
he ain't no joke.
He's from Tennessee cause I see Mike Pyle,
he talks different bro.
I love Denmark Bro.
I know.
I don't know these things.
You know he's a bad motherfucker.
Fuck you find the wrong fight in that fight.
But he could've won that fight.
Jake shields was exhausted,
man.
He had cut 20 pounds in a day to get down to one 70 cause you know,
he had been fighting in one 85 in strike force and he put out,
you said that during the break put on some muscle man.
He had a real hard time making that one 70 a real hard time.
He was dead in the water and Cameron just didn't quite,
I was,
you know,
I was really thinking the Cameron was going to pull it off.
You know,
I didn't want to say it.
I didn't want to say before the fight,
but when I saw what shape Jake was in the,
the,
the Wayans right before we went on,
I was like,
this guy looks like he has aids.
Like he looks like he's dehydrated.
It looks like you hate about good,
terrible pro.
I was shocked.
Like he looked so terrible that I saw him.
I shook his hand.
I was like,
whoa.
Like there's some guys that look,
the worst I ever saw was Travis looter when Travis Luder was going to fight
Anderson Silva.
Listen man,
he weighed in twice.
I was there for the first way.
Then he looked terrible.
He had dry chapped lips.
He was gone too,
is sucked in.
And then he didn't make weight.
And so we had another hour,
I think,
or two hours to make weight.
Well,
he tried to make,
wait another 45 minutes and then he shuffled over to this scale.
He couldn't walk bro.
He couldn't walk like the Jake had a walk upstairs to get through the,
the weird stairs was,
and you could see him like as he was walking upstairs,
it was like,
it was awkward.
It was awkward watching them walk.
That's how exhausted he was.
And then he got on the scale,
nothing like,
like what's his face like a Travis looter Travis Luder.
It looked like he was dead.
He looked that Guy Zombie Bro.
He looked like a dead man that was walking.
He was looked like a guy who had been poisoned and 24 hours after that he was
supposed to be the baddest
motherfucker on the planet and Anderson Silva in 24 hours and he walks over and
he still can't make weight.
He's still like a pound and a half off.
There's no way you can lose it.
He's just fucked.
He just would just calculated it wrong or you know,
he didn't lose enough fat or he didn't stick to his diet.
The weight watchers tell him,
Brian Calvin does fucking points.
These guys are,
they're there.
This,
they've got it down to a science,
so much fucking weight,
cutting 20 pounds,
you know,
a lot of them are cutting 20 pounds and they do it slowly.
One of the Dye Doggie Yang,
a Korean dude who fought on the card,
he lost a Chris Como Zoo.
Very,
very close and controversial decision.
A lot of people thought that he should have won,
but he was at legends on Monday,
cutting weight on Monday,
on Monday.
And the fight the Wayne's not until Friday,
but he was at legends cutting weight already on Monday.
So that motherfucker's losing like probably he's probably losing 20 pounds and
he's doing it over a course of like five days.
Cause he looked huge when he got into the cage.
The giant musclebound dude,
you know,
it's just these guys have it down to a science how to dehydrate yourself and
then come back.
So that was,
if Kampman had a time,
that was his time,
man,
he could have,
he could have won that fight,
especially if he pushed away and just started firing on them in the third round.
Mccammon Saul bad-ass striker,
his fucking striking is clean man.
If you look at that policy,
I go,
fine.
That's a beautiful representation of his skills because Paul Tiago is like this
really rough and tumble bad mother fucker and he's got dynamite in his hands,
knocked out Josh Koscheck and Martin Cameron just picks him apart.
Dude picked him apart standing using his jab and leg kicks and just angles like
everything you mean?
Paula just got like outclass in the feet.
He swinging these wild.
I mean if they hit you,
you're fucked.
He's swinging some sledge hammers,
but he ain't even getting close to hitting Cameron.
And I was like,
man,
Kampman skills are so much better than Jake shields as a kickboxer.
I just don't know why he was trying to engage them in grappling.
You know?
He came close a couple times,
like I was like,
maybe he's going to prove me wrong.
It looks like we locked up a couple of jokes almost.
He almost got it.
But that mother fucker is so hard to tap.
Jake shields is so heart attack.
May Him almost got him.
May Him had his back.
Yes,
it had it fully locked in May.
I'm almost got him.
But mom's big ma'ams big as fuck.
You know,
mayhem is a big one,
80 fiver and he's strong in his Jujitsu's very,
very underrated.
You know,
I've had two guys that I rolled with,
just ran right through me mayhem and Jake shields,
both of them,
both of those guys where I felt like I was help us.
Nothing I could do with them.
They're just too too goddamn strong.
Jake shields is a bad ass wrestler.
He's just his grappling and his Jujitsu.
It's just,
his technique is awesome and he's strong as shit.
He knows what the fuck he's doing and I'm like,
Cameron has disadvantaged there.
I wonder why he's like engaging this dude.
And if Jake wasn't like really beat down,
I mean the fact that Jake was beat down like that and he was still able to get
takedowns are still able to reverse position at mountain and get some dominant
spots on shows you how bad asses grappling is.
But kampmanns kickboxing is like,
like if Jake Shield is like a purple belt.
Kampmanns a fucking straight
black belt in stand up.
His standup is crisp man.
He does everything good.
Everything perfect the way he moves his footwork.
There's a big gap between him and Jake Shields.
Jake shields is like Plod,
punch,
kick.
His Kid,
his body kicks pretty good on his left side.
He throws good body kicks.
He'll throw some good leg kicks too.
But really he's just trying to get the clench and take your ass down and if he's
too tired to do that,
like in that round with the third round with Kampman and shields,
I thought I was going to move away.
I thought why would he grapple with them in this round?
This is the round where he could jack them.
Kevin's one of those dudes though it like,
he's just like just outside the very,
very best.
But he,
you could see him like launch into the very best like with any one big
performance.
You know what I'm saying?
My keys.
One of those guys like,
like Carlos Condit La Carlos condit just leaped into one of the very best when
he knocked out Dan Hardee when he knocked out Dan Hardee,
I was like,
okay,
this mother Fucker,
you know,
like everyone knew he was a Badass.
Everyone knew he had that real close flight with camp in,
which was a fucking incredible war.
And then a real close fight with Jake Ellenberger at another fucking animal.
Ellenberger is a beast.
So you knew that Carlos condit was a bad mother fucker,
but when he knocked out Dan Hardee it was like,
okay,
this dude is,
not only is he a bad mother fucker,
but he's like getting better all the time.
He's like hitting new levels.
He's trained with Jon Jones like every day.
Bad mother clock I didn't make because you know,
I would've done it with Eddie and I,
you can't tell the truth.
Be told the truth that I couldn't have said that.
I like to listen.
I love Dan Hadi.
I think talent to shit.
But Carlos conduit I think showed me some of the,
was that Jake Ellenberger who's getting beat up for the first two rounds and
came back and said shit to him and it's the silver type elbow from the inside.
I was like,
that kid's got balls.
He's got mad balls,
balls,
call Congress.
Carlos hate the mix of that alley with that mother fucker.
Cause he might turn the lights out on yet permanently.
Either the type of guy that might turn them out on your permit.
He's a bad mother.
Fucks up my bottom scares the shit is getting better.
He's gotten better.
He's done in one of the best camps in the fucking way.
Yeah.
Those guys don't fuck around man.
And that Trevor Whitman man,
he,
that guy is a very good striking cause he is.
He's doing sky.
Yeah.
I want to give them a shout out.
He's a fucking good guy and he's a,
he's a bad mother.
Fuck.
I know he works for them.
And then uh,
also um,
fuck.
What is this an answer?
Pray.
Nope.
Shut up man.
The fuck up man.
Sorry princess.
Um,
I feel like an asshole for not remembering the guy's name.
Which one?
The Guy who's the main guy at Jackson's.
That's the mains tracking trainer.
Cause he's a great guy.
Trevor Whitman is a guy who's had a grudge grudges in Denver,
correct?
Right.
I'm going to,
I'm going to have to Google this real quick because I've got to give that guy
his props cause he's doing an awesome job too.
I want to give a prop to my man,
Ali Baas,
whatever your name is from Australia on Twitter.
Always sending me love is shit looking out for all of us.
He had red banded Joe.
Who's,
who's that?
Oh that's,
that's,
I didn't know what Joe is looking at that until you put somebody on red band.
What's the matter with you?
You look all
fucking this sleepy at what's going on.
She was listening,
you know,
I thought Jake shields the last that I thought he,
Jake Shields I thought for sure was pulling for cattlemen with everything I had.
Cause I,
and I love Jake shields,
but camping is just this guy that he's right there,
you know.
Do you remember hanging out with Mike Winkeljohn.
Thank you.
Sorry John.
I'm going to drag that.
I smoke too much weed.
I forgot his name,
but he's a,
he's a great striking coach.
He's,
you know what I was really impressed with with Carlos condit and that fight with
Dan Hardee was the technique that he threw that left hooked with,
if you look at the both guys throw the punch of the exact same time really,
but Carlos was was perfect.
Carlos was instead of coming wide,
he came,
he came like with a perfect angle to the punch and it was perfect accuracy and
his other hand was up.
You know,
he,
he did it with perfect technique and he nailed them.
He caught him in the exchange and that's like a perfect lesson for people to
learn.
I keep saying perfect,
but if you,
if that's one of the most important things is to concentrate on technique.
Yeah,
you can knock guys out with crazy,
wild,
loopy shit.
You can,
you can knock guys out with hay makers where you're fucking Chin is down and
your hands are up.
If you connect,
you can knock them out,
but that's not the best way to do it.
The best way to do it is to use the proper technique because if you do that,
you have more of a chance of knocking them out.
If you have big power into your fast,
you can get away with some goofy Shit like Roy Jones did when he was in his
prime.
But look what happened to Roy Jones once he started to slow down,
when he didn't have that crazy athleticism.
All of a sudden he couldn't pull off what he could.
But Bernard Hopkins still can.
Bernard Hopkins has perfect technique.
If Bernard Hopkins had the Athleticism of Roy Jones Jr,
I mean maybe that's why Bernard Hopkins does Bernard Hopkins,
it's like maybe,
you know like Jujitsu guys,
they always say the best Jujitsu guys are the guys that aren't physically strong
because they can't pull off anything else unless they have perfect technique.
You know,
cause it's all leveraged injection.
Yes.
I'm sorry,
say that.
Not Strong.
Really.
Yeah.
The most technical guys and the guys that aren't physically strong,
the most technical guys,
if you want to learn Jujitsu,
you always want to learn from a small guy because big guys have like coolers and
guillotines.
They do a lot of like power Jujitsu.
They'll do a lot of things that you can only get away with if you really strong.
Whereas a small guy has no options other than use perfect leverage and perfect
technique.
Hmm.
Yeah.
So you should learn you,
you're better off your bed.
Motherfucking when you open up your Little Cup full fucking school cops.
I don't want to teach anybody,
man.
I don't like teaching.
You know?
It's funny because my daughter,
do you really?
Yeah.
I thought you were going to kick back to you saying,
I've,
I've taught p friends and shit,
but it's,
you know the thing about,
you know,
if you want to like be a coach like a Winkeljohn or like a Trevor Whitman man,
that's your life,
dude.
You're dedicating yourself to,
to these guys and to their progress.
And it's a very fascinating thing,
but you gotta be willing to dedicate 100% that's the reason why I quit teaching
taekwondo is because I started doing standup comedy and I realized that I was
not going to be giving this a hundred percent of my time anymore.
And I had a bunch of guys that I was leading and tournaments.
And even though I had stopped fighting,
talk about no tournament and I was doing kickboxing,
I was still teaching at a taekwondo school and I was still leading people and
tournaments.
And so I would have these kids that I've coached and I'd bring them to life,
these beginner tournament's and I was dedicating a lot of time to it.
And I had a lot of people that had like 10 guys that were like really
competitive and a girl who was really competitive and she was really good.
And I spent a lot of time with them,
like many,
many hours every week,
you know,
like at least three nights,
four nights a week,
at least two hours a night.
Just dedicated to training with these kids and working with them and I knew that
once I started doing comedy and I needed my,
I couldn't be there at nighttime cause I had to go to do a Gig in Connecticut or
I couldn't be there and I'd have somebody else teaching it for me.
I'm like,
they're not going to do it the way I do it and this is not going to be the same
thing and this is not,
it's not fair and I don't want to half ass it and I don't want to feel shitty
about that.
The one thing that it made me feel good about my life ever was martial arts,
so I was like,
I can't not do this.
I can't fuck this up because I have to quit.
I can't like do a shit job at this.
I can't do a shit job at teaching because to me it was like one of the,
the the the defining moments in my life that I wasn't a loser.
Like when I was teaching taekwondo at Boston University,
I was like,
I'm teaching at a like a university.
Like,
I'm like an expert at something and I'm teaching people that want to learn this,
how to use it.
It's like one of the first times in my life I felt like I was worth something,
you know,
so there's no way I could fuck this up theirs.
So I just quit.
I just quit teaching.
And that's how I feel like,
like right now,
like,
you know,
I get interested in strategy and I,
I get interested when I see guys fight.
Uh,
what,
uh,
what I think is a very unintelligent fight and they don't have the proper
coaching.
They don't have someone who's like really mapped out a game plan.
A lot of these dudes are really good and because they're really good,
they know what they can do and they know what they want to do.
And they sorta like plot out their own plan in a fight,
which is all well and good,
but sometimes you need someone who's also really good,
also has a really good knowledge of this and is outside of it looking in because
someone was outside of like a Greg Jackson who's looking in,
there's one of the reasons why,
you know,
like,
like a Dave camp,
Mario and Bob Cook,
they're outside.
They see the whole thing.
They're very intelligent and they're very immersed in the game.
Like Bob Cook and Dave Cambria,
they break down fighters,
they spend time,
they go over tapes,
they analyze shit.
And when it comes down to a fight,
they've got a very intelligent strategy.
And if you listened to that strategy and you follow that game plan,
you're,
you have a very good chance of winning.
You know,
there's going to be variations.
Shit's gonna happen.
You're gonna have to make adjustments.
But of course you do.
That's part of the game.
You know there's going to be shit happens.
Okay?
You can't take them down.
Listen,
you got to kick that motherfucker's legs.
Okay?
If you can't kick them down and he wants to stand up with you,
he's open for that inside leg kick and then you have to have a,
you know,
here's plan B.
Okay,
now we're here.
Okay?
You're,
you think you broke your foot?
Okay,
stop throwing kicks is what you're gonna do.
You're gonna,
you're gonna bait him.
You going to get him into exchange and fire off the left hook.
He's opened for a left hook.
You know what I'm saying?
Like they have this all thought out.
They have it thought out like that.
The guy thought out every 14 plan,
everything.
I mean,
it's amazing how there's so much more into this than what you would think you
need fucking
moron and go hit the bag.
You know,
you have Jujitsu,
you have your strength and conditioning.
It's amazing how,
you know what I noticed,
and I don't know if you notice,
I'm going to start doing a column for pro MMA Joe.
Yeah,
yeah.
Once a week or once a month.
Right.
Just writing
something and it's weird.
He goes,
what's your first column going to be about?
And,
and I and I noticed that the last two years,
every time I've gone to an MMA event with you,
somebody else in the UFC division is losing way.
They're trying to get healthy.
And this last time I went to Austin,
you got Bert,
Bert lost 50 60 pounds.
Our friend's mom lost a bunch of wages.
Great.
Now and I seen another guy and then we have our buddy deeper squad who we've
bumped up,
he's a big cause of the sleep apnea.
So we and how Emma May affect some people,
like I was sick and tired of going into those fights are really fat.
Fuck when you see all those people in shape.
And then when I went through this last year,
I've see,
I heard,
I haven't seen that.
They put two different tables at like they put tables,
we cookies and cakes.
Then they had tables with like healthy snacks.
And it's so weird like these people when you're around this,
this is what MMA has done for me.
I'm not a fighter and I don't want to do Jujitsu with nothing.
But being around those guys,
you're like,
fuck,
I gotta be healthy.
Whenever I watched those UFC,
uh,
you know,
24,
seven,
whatever they are like,
I think it definitely inspires Pedro's bias.
People every time to,
every time I go to a UFC event,
somebody else's on a diet or somebody else's getting healthy or somebody else's
eating healthy,
and that's what I've seen from another man.
It started with me.
That ultimate fight of the year take was on it.
The,
the kid that lost a hundred something pounds from doing Jujitsu.
He's not in the UFC no more.
But he talked about it and he goes,
you know,
even if I just final in this,
at least people lose weight and try this.
I forget what his name was.
He had like a Mohawk and a kid and he really pushed love for the kid.
He made a ton of Todd Hays.
Yeah,
he was.
He lost like 130 pounds or something.
He's a bad motherfucker.
No,
no,
no.
Not Todd Hays.
No,
no,
no.
Isn't it Josh?
Shit.
Josh Hays.
I was at a talk to you about Josh bring their pain.
Hey,
what the fuck?
I had a kid and he had a Mohawk
blonde hair on that he had and he really loved his wife.
He seemed like a release and see a guy.
Yeah.
He lost a Shitload,
a shitload of weight,
and it's amazingly how every time I go to UFC event now somebody else is on a
diet.
So he was drinking
the chains.
Josh bring the pain.
Hanes,
sorry.
It's amazing how it's rubbed off on some pizza.
He was on the same seasons tape.
Yeah.
I told him saying it was only they would take.
That's why it was a weird high.
Every time I go I see somebody and it's just inspiring to me,
you know?
I don't know.
Yeah,
man.
I think that's one of the things that I would be interested in doing outside of
doing comedy outside of like of all the stuff that I get fascinated by pool and
all that was,
that is one thing that I would get interested in doing.
Opening up a gym training fighters,
but and you know,
just being like sort of a Greg Jackson type of guy having ideas and strategies
and helping you know,
people through.
But that would have to be something,
I'm 100% dedicated.
You can't fuck around with that.
And how fast that man,
that's not something to have fast.
You know,
you're,
you,
you are taking people who have a limited window in the sport,
you know,
a fighter can fight from the time they're 18 till there,
most guys,
38 48 48 if you're Randy 38 if you're a normal human,
you know,
so yeah,
the only,
if,
if you know,
that's,
that's it.
You got 20 years and during that time if you really ended up a bunch of wars,
cut that time down substantially.
Anytime you have a big war,
anytime you have a craving,
if that's your style,
you know you want a Vandelay Silva it like,
like vandal used to do in the early days.
Well no matter what your you,
it's going to shorten your career a bit.
You're not going to be 48 years old fighting like that.
That's a different kind of style.
One thing that you've always talked about that is very,
you see it and find this fridge off the shits loud.
It's the gyms that have the gym wars,
the camps where they have gym wars.
Yeah.
You could see those guys that yeah,
there a little seasoned and stuff,
but they'd been hit in the head a couple more times and regular regular guys.
As you can really see those gym wars are the ones who were really kill you.
Yeah.
You have to have guys that you're training with that you trust and you have to
be careful not to hurt each other.
You know,
guys hurt each other sometimes,
you know,
it's just,
it's by accident or just because they're training hard.
I mean that's just a part of the game.
But you gotta be careful with,
uh,
just gyms where they just basically fight every week.
Like every week you're fighting every week,
two,
three times a week.
You guys are blasted each other,
you know,
you're fighting,
you basically get in the end.
Then one good thing about it,
as you get used to fighting,
you get used to give me any tag.
You get used to being in there in the pocket.
You're going to be a tough motherfucker to get into the cage with because this
shit is going down in your life every day you're used to it.
You're used to full blast blows.
But on the other side,
you know,
you can only do that for so long.
If you do that in and take big,
big shots all the time on a regular basis,
your,
your career gets shortened substantially.
Your brain is only set up,
you know,
to take a certain amount of abuse before the just way too much damage and all
this stuff they're finding out now about football players.
You know,
when they're there,
they're examining their brains after he's died special.
I told you about the little gap.
Oh yeah.
Very amazing.
Yeah,
Eddie.
Eddie told me about that too.
It was very intricate.
That's special.
Fucking scary shit man.
I watched the other one where it was that football player.
Um,
I believe he played for Harvard,
uh,
in college and then after college he became a pro wrestler and he suffered a
gang of concussions.
And this is one of the reasons why I brought up the Brock Lesnar situation.
Cause those guys suffer a lot of concussions a lot.
They get,
they take a lot of hard shots.
There's a video,
Brock Lesnar,
Brock Lesnar is on top of the third rope.
I don't know who he was wrestling against,
but he was on top of the third rope and he jumps up through the air and does
like a fucking three flip,
but miscalculates and lands on his head.
Dude,
he's 300 pounds.
Okay.
And he throws himself through the air flips and lands on his head.
He should be dead.
You got to see the video.
Here's the video.
If you watch the video,
any normal person would be dead.
Okay.
Watch this shit.
We're watching on youtube.
Watch this
dude.
He landed on his head.
He landed on his fucking head.
Yeah.
He completely miscalculated the jump completely.
Landowners get and still finish the pin.
I'll retweet the link on my Twitter.
Raise brains.
You want to talk to scrambled eggs?
His brains should be a small half cup of oatmeal in the bottom of an empty bowl.
They should be dead.
It should have crushed his whole brain.
I mean,
for me,
if that was me or you and we did that,
we'd be dead,
but that guy's fine.
That's why I said like if that happened during this one that we saw,
how many times did he accidentally banged his head?
Other times,
I mean,
they're there.
These guys are gigantic dudes and they're throwing each other.
I mean,
people don't realize the abuse that people's bodies take on pro wrestling.
The reason why a lot of those guys get hooked on painkillers.
Pro Wrestling is one of the most difficult things to do in all of show business.
Even in all of sports,
even though it's not really a sport,
I mean per se,
I mean there's predetermined outcomes.
It still requires an incredible amount of athleticism and incredible amount of
work.
These guys are on the road like every night down the road,
several nights a week,
performing shows,
throwing each other through the air.
They have to come up with new,
more spectacular moves to satisfy people.
That's why they're jumping off ropes.
They're jumping off the top of the fucking cage and they're flipping and doing
this.
And you grabbed by ankles and I'm gonna throw you through the air and then you
land on your back.
And then I jumped through my and I flip and I land on you.
They fucking bonk heads and shit all the time.
These guys are getting knocked the fuck out and practice.
What do you do?
Well and put some ice on it and see tomorrow and tomorrow.
You better get your fucking moves down.
I just want to keep your WWE contract.
Did he also play football too?
Yeah,
he,
yeah,
he played.
Um,
I think he tried out for the Vikings.
Listen to his numbers because this is where it gets really crazy.
Okay.
I mean,
yeah.
PROC is not like the best MMA fighter.
He does not have the best striking technique.
He does not have the best Jujitsu.
But when you talk about just a freak athlete,
his 40 yard sprint,
4.6 seconds,
225 pound bench press,
he can do 43 reps,
his vertical jump,
35 inches,
his broad jump,
10 fucking feet,
10 feet.
Do you imagine this is at 300 pounds,
310 pounds.
You imagine a fucking guy,
310 pounds,
throwing himself 10 feet through the air and he still could have stopped at Paj
was talking and stop came.
So what the fuck?
What are we talking about here?
No,
no.
Listen.
The ability to him to apply for and it goes down.
I mean,
how long has the ability to move?
Your body keeps saying that in the podcast about how good he moves.
All those fucking football players move on.
Yeah.
Those are the guys that have come online when you see an offensive lineman.
Oh yeah,
90 and they super athletes.
These mother fuckers,
they're all like that.
Could you imagine if a Michael Vick wanted to get into MMA?
Amazing.
How bad he would fuck people up.
Oh that guy.
If a guy like that,
that level of athlete dedicated hymns,
I mean there are guys like that.
There's a few,
there's a few that are in there now.
But these,
those super athletes like Michael Jordan,
you know,
if a Michael Jordan decided to,
from the time he was [inaudible] to beat you,
you'd have to bet on themselves.
Joy would love that.
She would fight.
Listen,
cause his wife could bet for him.
He can go to Vegas and if he was fighting,
he was like put everything on a thousand people,
Benton photo.
That motherfucker,
he would beat Ladelle if he'd bet on himself.
Cause he had,
he was,
he let go with a chair.
Dude,
he was such an accolade additive motherfucker member.
How he would when he was the first guy that would literally fly through the
fucking air slamming in dunks where you would see it on the highlight reels on
like ESPN.
You'd see it on the news and people would just be standing there shaking their
head going,
how the fuck can he do that?
He was flying with his tongue out,
flying through the air,
smashing that ball through there.
I mean,
I didn't even follow basketball and all I saw was that dude doing these
superhuman feats of athleticism.
If that guy does sat.
You mentioned that flying need,
Jordan can hit you with choose Christ.
Could you imagine the flying doubled me like a fucking Jose Aldo style that
Michael Jordan could hit you with if Michael Jordan dedicated his time to that
instead of basketball,
God damn,
he'd be a bad motherfucker.
Those guys are coming,
man.
Those guys are coming those.
That's the next wave of MMA.
The next wave of LMA is super athletes.
Show Davis,
John,
I mean John [inaudible],
Lesnar and Lesnar.
Look,
he doesn't know the game yet.
He's relatively inexperienced.
He's only had six fights,
seven fights.
You know,
that's not that many,
man.
That's not,
that's not enough to be fighting.
What does he,
ah,
he fought the Korean gentleman in his UFC debut.
Then he fought Frank Mir and got leg blocked and then he fought a Keith haring
and beat him on decision.
Then he fought a Randy and he beat Randy and got the title and then he fought
Frank Mir,
Frank Mir again,
that's five.
And then he fought,
is it just six and then he fought six,
seven,
eight,
eight.
Really I counted seven either way it's relatively relatively inexperienced and
right away thrust into the deep end of the throat to the fucking,
the guy as an NCAA national champion had some serious technique.
There's no way you become a champion wrestler if you're just wrong because those
guys are just strong too.
I mean you have to have some serious technique.
So He's,
he can learn,
he just has to be brought up correctly.
Some what he really,
really should have done with him.
It's hard with heavyweights.
So cause there's not as many guys that are willing to fight a guy like that.
You know when you're coming up,
like who the fuck's gonna fight him in the king of the cage once he going to
learn out of that,
you know what I mean?
He's gotta be tested somehow.
So there's like a weird middle ground.
Like you got to get 'em in Bella tore.
You know what I'm saying?
You got to get them to fight guys that are just a hair under strike force level
just to have,
we'll strike force in the UFC right now.
They're pretty close with Alastar.
Well starring fatal or and you know,
for dooms capable of beating anybody if he gets them in the right position.
There's,
and Josh Barnett,
he's a dangerous mother fucker.
There's some dangerous guys.
Antonio de Silva,
you're not quite the same level as UFC.
But I think that like when a guy comes up that's got that much potential,
like a Brock Lesnar,
like,
you know,
it's like you gotta,
you gotta make sure that you take the most advantage
out of these physical gifts.
You know,
you've got to bring them up the right way or just throw him in like they did
man.
But like they did,
they made a ton of money.
I mean everybody made a ton of money,
but I just feel that money they're about to make now with the fucking Mexicans
is off the chart.
Jag.
Yeah.
It just opened up that UFC Latino with the paper view.
This is PR.
They were already it shoot super bowl Sunday in two years.
They're putting fucking though Santos in this guy up quick Jack.
Are they really?
Oh yeah.
This is going to get are going to be Christmas or I'll fucking [inaudible].
There'd be new year's or it'll be super bowl weekend a for sure to it.
If it's super bowl weekend,
we're both shit.
It's going to be [inaudible].
It would be yet just Julia in her chin is going to be
king.
Congress has Godzilla.
Go Santos versus Cain Velasquez might be,
I might have a fucking heart attack.
I might not be able to get through the broadcast.
I might.
I might just shit my pants before we even start.
I might just,
I might just have uncontrollable diarrhea and bought it for Super Bowl.
They're not going to lie for why?
Wait,
let's put it up there.
Santos is coming off a big fight to that Roy Jones slip fight or the Roy Nelson
fight rather was a real good fight for him because he got pushed and he had a
work.
He had to work for three hard rounds because Roy Nelson is no joke man.
Roy Nelson is a powerful motherfucker and he can take it and Dosantos hit him
with some bombs and he had to go three hard rounds with him.
It was like a real like grueling fight where you know Roy Nelson hit him with
some shots to,
Nelson was always there and always dangerous.
Who's looking new?
Used car dog aggression against red head against Frankie.
A Gray Maynard,
right?
I don't know.
I don't know exactly what's a setup yet.
I think it's all tentative right now.
I'm not sure Carl would hurt his back for 25 he did.
Yeah.
He's head of his next fight.
Really?
When did this happen?
All those heavyweight scene that fight and fell off their fucking lunch and this
happened yesterday.
They all did him.
Frank Mir fell off shore car pulled out.
I thought Carla was,
oh no,
I won't pull that on one 25 that suck.
He hurt his back.
Who else?
Somebody else pulled out a couple pullouts.
Really car pulls out of January Cobain.
I hate
having some back pain and an MRI s did some damage that may require you're
reading it.
Yeah,
I have some damage that may really require surgery.
Oh No.
Well you know he had some serious back problems wrestling,
you know,
when he was wrestling and some serious back problems and it's one of the reasons
why he um,
I think,
uh,
stop playing football as well because uh,
I think he played football for a bit.
Somebody else's hurt too from one of the cars 24 and cro cop interested in
replacing Carwyn versus Nelson.
Whoa.
Cro.
Cop wants to step in and fight Roy Nelson.
Roy Nelson might not cro cop the fuck out right out back to Croatia and that
crazy fucking blanket and not crazy that you would say that.
Crazy,
crazy.
I'll say that,
but crazy talk.
He might,
you know,
or Cro.
Cop might just come back with a fucking flurry.
You never know when a guy's
done because if you look at it like Alistair Overeem,
a lot of people counted.
Alistair Overeem out.
A lot of people said,
man,
this guy just keeps getting knocked out by people.
Surgery.
Keratan have knocked him out.
Chocolate.
Dell knocked him out.
I think a shogun stopped him once.
I mean there's just like he got,
he had all these fights where he's getting beat down and I think a lot of people
said,
you know what,
this guy is just done.
And then he went up to heavyweight and then he got all sudden dedicated and then
all of a sudden he's the baddest mother fucker and k one he's the most dangerous
guy that's fighting and strike force the most.
I think he's more dangerous than any of those other Strikeforce guys.
I know faders a legend.
I know failure is a bad mother fucker and I'm a fade or fan,
but I think fatal or stands with Alistair Overeem,
I think it's night night soldier.
I don't think you can hang in there with that guy.
I don't think you realize the level of striking that guys on right now.
He's been training just straight K one for a long time now and competing and
winning in high end,
you know,
a high level competition against high level competition,
beating Peter Arts and shit.
You know,
so there's,
there's a a gang of those dudes right now that are,
that are,
that are bad.
Motherfuckers was sub Joe Rogan's dropping,
I'll be his shit.
Cro Cop could come back,
he could come back if as long as he can still take punishment,
you know,
I mean the other day with a big knee from big guy,
but if he could still take punishment and he sued,
you know,
super dedicated himself to sides.
Fuck this,
I'm coming back.
You know,
I'm coming back with a vengeance.
Him Against Roy Nelson.
It could be fun.
I'm sitting there the other day watching Tito against Matt Hamill.
What?
I've always loved apple.
I like his work ethic.
I always pull from and I'm watching the Tito or whatever.
I don't thinking about fucking judge Joel to pick this guy up of rule around
like a fucking rag doll like a rag doll.
I never,
I was thinking about this this week.
I'm looking at this goal.
This is what's in.
Let me with John Jones handles dudes,
it's like you ever seen a leg like a strong bug,
like a beetle.
Pick another bug up and just kind of toss it around.
Like bugs can do crazy shit to each other.
Like ants can just pick other ants.
I'll bug there nothing and just toss them around.
It doesn't learn either even strain and that's how it looks like when Jon Jones
chose could go around that.
That gave my heart stop dude.
He fucking stop his lateral drop when he gets those devils double over hooks on
you that he hit hoody hit with it.
He hit the guy.
Would that Stephan Bonner,
Stephan Bonner with it.
You hit go smile with it.
He goes miles.
His first opponent in UFC,
he a apparently Tait Fletcher told me that he hit it on Keith Jardeen and
training.
He said,
dude,
you can't even believe it when you see it.
Keith is as big,
strong,
powerful dude and Jon Jones just launches them through the air,
flips him over his head.
I mean,
you know a lateral job is you're flipping a guy threw the fucking air,
feet up to ankles flying and he and he does that to keep charging on a regular.
He's just that strong eyes.
He just freak strong freak technique.
Super Smart,
super humble dude.
You know that's,
that's the next level man.
That level of athleticism that comes with those guys.
That's the next level that's coming right now.
Jon Jones is just like all those other super athletes in other sports.
Just like a Jordan.
He's just one of these guys.
He's just all bad fucker.
Bad motherfucker
with his mind.
But that mother Fucker,
we don't have a downfall too.
What they also have a,
there's a dark side to the middle.
We'll have what you were talking about before,
which is technique.
They relied too much on left lettuces.
Oh Jon Jones has a perfect world.
It draws as they're more involved in it.
And that's what happens to Michael Vick.
For example,
Jordan rely on technique.
I don't know much about basketball.
Did He,
was he a technique guy or was he just an athletic guy?
He was very athletic,
but he knew the game of basketball and,
and they had to be,
he was one of the greatest basketball.
But what I'm saying is we're trying to fighting,
sometimes people have very fast the hand speed or that good with their legs,
they move good,
but they just don't for the CISM stops and you flow always lose the technique.
You know,
like,
like you'll never be a GSP.
He said,
great athlete become motherfucker.
Got Great techniques,
techniques.
Perfect.
It's perfect.
You know.
And that's just so John Donner heard the guy who handles,
uh,
he's,
he does a lot of the training of GSP and a lot of the strategy of GSP.
And he was brought in to coach with GSP on this season.
The ultimate fighter.
You saw him?
He is he Australian dude write shorthand.
I'm sorry.
New New Zealand wasn't there.
He does,
yeah.
He's like 43 years old and Jujitsu is this guy's life and he's,
he's a brilliant motherfuckers on his man.
I heard he sleeps on the mat when he takes naps and shit cause he teaches during
the day.
You know when he's got no classes,
he's just take her naps in.
Showroom is a fucking man.
Oh really?
Where he sleeps in my thing and he's won a lot of legend behind this guy.
I heard that like,
he's one of these guys like us,
like you know like as a comic,
sometimes the best material you get is right about before you close your fucking
eyes and you have a decision to me.
Either you could get up and write the joke or you could get up and say to
yourself,
I remember the morning and then you don't remember what got in the morning.
It's this motherfucking tastes it to the next level.
He's in bed thinking of a move.
He'll get up at four in the morning to get a job to a rolling,
start rolling with the fucking,
you know,
whatever.
Just to see if leverage or whatever.
I heard,
he's one of those guys,
you know,
that they credit him with inventing the Darce choke.
There's a,
there's a choke that,
uh,
Joe DRC is famous for because mayhem Miller got caught in it by Joe DRC and they
brought it back and they started calling it the Darce choke.
And I talked about it during the podcast,
but apparently what I've been informed since I said this during the broadcast is
that Donna her actually invented this choke that he,
he figured it out and he's the one who showed at the DRC and DRC showed at the
mayhem.
So Donna,
you know,
he's a legend in fighting a legend in like,
he doesn't fight himself cause he's got a fucked up name,
but he's a legend amongst Jujitsu circles for being like one of the baddest
motherfuckers to deal with.
Well,
his theories are exactly,
they mirror my theories when it comes to MMA and it's the theory that they
espoused when coaching this,
this,
uh,
show the ultimate fighter.
They're like,
fuck all this.
Trying to be the toughest,
you know,
guy trying to run up hills the hardest and throw bags of sand around the
hardest.
No,
what's most important is your technique.
The technique has to be the most important and it's not mental toughness.
It's not your ability to,
you know,
hold your breath underwater,
holding onto rocks.
It's technique,
technique and training.
That tech,
that technique at a furious pace and you'll develop or how to fight you.
How do you learn?
You learn,
you grow with the Gen tool,
what you're running up a hill.
That's something I've never,
it's great.
Conditioning is great.
There's something to strengthen,
conditioning to prevent injuries and to give you a certain amount of strength to
a certain amount of power to,
to utilize those techniques.
But when you get past that technique is the most important time.
So,
and these guys,
you know,
this Donna,
her guy like talking to him just reinforces in my eyes the,
the importance of a super dedicated coach.
Like a guy like him,
you know,
a guy who camera down like Craig Jackson,
especially Don,
I'm,
I'm a big fan of his as Anna and Greg's,
those guys are huge for fighter's career.
You know,
to find a wise guy who is in that role.
He's not,
he can't compete.
He's guy.
He was born with a fucked up Nate.
Like he literally,
he can't like do strength and conditioning shade.
He can't run his,
his knees fucked up.
You probably can't take kicks in it.
So he's not going to be fighting.
But he's fascinated by and he's fascinated by it as a science.
Just like you'd be fascinated by chess as a science.
And that's how he breaks it down.
Say it's not about toughness or ego or any silliness like that.
It's all just about executing the perfect technique and strategies.
You watch the ultimate final last week.
Yes.
They had a knuckle head on there and he walks around and he tough.
But then the other guy or it'd be says avoid his fucking guilty.
Yep.
Did you see what [inaudible] just dove in on the fucking Giliad's?
Yeah.
Well,
it's cause the kid came wild at him and he just forced him into his habits.
Do you think that that kick could beat the fuck out of me,
that kid with the guillotine because I got kids,
got a nasty guy.
Well he's got a weird way of holding it to absolutely.
He doesn't hold it like a normal guy does.
He like turns it so that the back of the palm is facing the face and he pushes
down on it and it kind of closes off both sides of the net quicker.
I'm,
I'm fucking around with it.
A lot of guys did.
Nate Diaz did that to um,
uh,
the fuck did you find God dammit Irish hangry named Marcus Davis.
He did that same technique to Marcus Davis.
He pushes his knuckles.
It pushes,
like grabs a hold of his hand and pushes his hand towards the neck and then
that's how it closes it off.
It's like,
that's the thing about Jujitsu man.
Car guys are constantly coming up with new variations to techniques,
constantly adding new ways to do it.
[inaudible] you will have variations.
Yeah,
position's going away.
You can't learn it all man.
And it's like that's like there's,
every guy has a different kind of style.
Like some guys always have the newest,
craziest moves and they have this giant encyclopedia of boobs they can hit you
with.
And then there's other guys that only like hit a certain amount of moves all the
time.
Like they go for arm,
triangle chokes armbar they have like three or four moves,
you know that they only go to off their back.
They have like armbar triangle.
That's it.
There's just only moves they go to.
But they're nasty.
Adam,
you know like Nogueira know Garret doesn't do like crazy wild stuff.
His Jujitsu is like old school Hicks and Gracie style Jujitsu.
It's like the real traditional Jujitsu.
But everything he does he does perfect.
You know what I'm saying?
Like everything is perfect technique.
Like,
like I don't see no guera doin,
you know any crazy like Gogo Plata rubber guard sweep shit.
Like he's going to just tap you a triangles TAPI with armbars.
You know what I'm saying?
Tap.
You would give teens,
get your back,
choke you out,
all like the standard stuff.
Like how'd your Gracie,
same thing.
All the standard standard moves.
They just hold them to a science,
you know?
So there's two schools of thought.
Like Hixon Gracie is a perfect example,
widely recognized as the greatest Jujitsu guy ever.
Everybody says that,
but Hixon Gracie's traditional Jujitsu,
that's what he hits you with.
He doesn't hit you with some crazy moves you never saw before.
He just goes through remove,
perfect.
He knows everyone,
he knows everything,
but his Jujitsu is all very standard old school Jujitsu.
He's just perfect at it.
Everything he does is perfect technique,
perfect position.
He's been there a billion times.
It's a part of his DNA and everybody says the same thing.
You don't even know what the Fuck Jujitsu is until your role with Hickson.
They say he just,
he just takes it to another level.
He goes,
it's just,
you realize like there's levels to this game and you think you know what the
levels are until you roll with the guy like Hickson and just realize this
motherfucker.
No,
it's exactly what to do.
Every time you move a certain way,
he knows exactly how to respond and he does it effortlessly and you,
you feel like you're a child.
You feel like you just learn how to do this and you getting strangled me more.
You've been putting in 10 years,
you've been going to the gym three,
four days a week for 10 years,
sweating your ass off,
doing fucking running hills,
doing kettlebell drills.
You're like,
I'm a bad mother fucker.
I'm 28 years old.
I did a cycle of antiviral.
Where's Hickson?
And your role with them and you just kept the rolled around like a little baby,
like a little baby.
You don't even know what the fuck's going on.
All techniques.
So say you don't feel any of his strength.
You don't even feel a strength.
You don't feel it.
It's just all of sudden he's mounted on you and you can't shake them off and try
to shake them off.
He counters that shake.
He's all of a sudden got an arm trapped and you're trying to fight that arm.
All of sudden you're in a triangle.
It's like it just boom,
boom,
boom.
And then he tapped and you're like,
I don't even feel like he got tired and even break a sweat.
You're exhausted.
You just fought for your fucking life against some ever,
ever moving anaconda.
That's figuring out some new way to cut off your blood.
And then boom,
tap and you have to tap and then you just humiliated and you start back from
scratch.
Can make tick technique,
brother technique and your technique.
Never fucking sponsor that.
Came to the flex flashlight,
flashlight,
flashlight.
Check him out like I said.
And when you put ice cubes in there and then you put a little bit of fucking
common there and then you put up the sauce in this and when you fucking did you
get the APP,
the Seltzer on your helmet.
Wait a minute,
wait.
And you get to the ice cube effect from outside your helmet.
You coming in and then you fucking,
I don't have this in my house,
I'm just trying to have one for you.
It's a blue one penalty.
I'm not gonna fuck nothing like that.
I don't like bored.
I'm just,
I just have ideas.
You still even beat out how often you beat off on a regular basis?
Once a week.
Really?
That's it.
Wow.
Why don't you do it more for what Brian wants to,
wants to hear stories now.
What did you do at two today?
Digging on the beat on.
Yeah.
Big on it.
No,
I feel fucking guilty.
It's always a sad feeling.
It's very sad when you'd beat off the club and make believe this strip is going
to
meet you at Denny's afterwards.
You know what I'm saying?
I ain't never going to happen and he never gonna fucking happen.
You always get that one of the adult in this go to Daddy.
She said she's going to meet me.
Fuck that little bit again to meet you.
What's up,
right?
That game son has to get the game.
Have you ever dated a girl that her phone has emergency porn videos just in case
that she doesn't have internet and she asked him masturbate?
No,
that's disgusting.
For real history.
Does that,
do you think she wants the world to know this?
Oh,
I don't know.
Probably not.
Yeah,
that seems like you just ratted her out bro.
Wow.
I got some chicks get crazy with the porn though.
They love it.
There's other girls that are offended by pouring some chicks,
get offended some chicks and get crazy with it.
It's a weird thing,
huh?
It's a weird thing.
Some girls think you need it like,
oh,
you need it to keep a relationship.
So there was a girl that I dated in high school and then,
uh,
so like I ran into her many,
many years later and somehow or another she got on the subject of getting bored
while she's married.
She was a horse probably wanting to fuck.
And uh,
she got on the subject of uh,
you know,
watching porn when you're married.
And I'm like,
you guys watch porn together?
She's like,
Oh yeah.
I mean,
after a while you get so tired of each other.
Just want to watch something else.
Like she was just,
it was like sounded so gross.
Why the fucking husband is fucking some tattooed pig
fucking filthy fucking animals that they are
old school ladies and gentlemen.
Oh Fuck Joey.
Joey is dropped old school.
I don't got time for this new shows.
US strong ass.
Yeah.
I was just trying to our sprint.
Joey,
you fucking threw it down today.
Today.
Yeah,
you did.
That was,
there was some classic moments when you said everything you said there was some
classic goddamn moments.
It was a one of my favorite podcasts.
Really?
Yeah.
Today you blowing smoke up my ass to throw down.
You made,
we come back.
Come up people's security cameras on and you made me laugh.
My fucking ass fucking guy.
That was a good one.
Anyway,
I love doing it with you guys.
A lot of fun.
Always.
What would happen?
Would you do nothing?
I was just getting the ending song writer.
He's nowhere.
You can't not do that.
Um,
do,
uh,
how do people get Ahold of your pay dot?
I fucking get ahold of,
no,
they don't.
They don't even bs podcast.
We drop these podcasts.
[inaudible] dot com [inaudible] dot com or download an now you guys on beauty
and the beast.com.
How the fuck did you get that?
I don't fucking know.
Beautiful Mind,
Doug.
Beast.
Oh da rather we just confused the shadow of business.
I don't know what you're saying.
Hold.
Mickey's going to be in my house.
Ever wondered about that?
Like what if you become famous,
you might not be able to keep that name like Disney might fuck with you guys and
dobbies my fuck was you guys.
We'll burn that bridge when we get to it.
Who gives them?
Why not just have other Joey d as in Felicia podcast?
I'd love you guys are off.
How about beauty and the beast?
Shut up Brian.
I don't know why.
Why is literally,
what the fuck?
What is?
Why not just have you guys do names?
What would it be?
Benefit.
Better beneficial to you guys.
If your name was on the podcast,
you know who the fuck knows?
Let's show ideas and Felicia.
Now why confused people just go to beauty and the beast.
Why?
Who gives a fuck just joined you?
Fuck people who love you,
man love you.
They want to find me.
They want to find the beast.com
they want other people to be able to find you on a Twitter.
I'm on my space.
Big like fuck off.
Your tags are off.
Nobody understands where you are.
Mad Flavor.
You need to get mad flavor.
Twitter had flavor at Twitter.
Uh,
what's My mad flavor?
What is your,
um,
I don't know.
Your Facebook,
you know when Coco Diaz,
if Facebook someone couldn't find you the vaporizer dude.
Yeah,
fine.
He's looking for you to stand on.
He couldn't find,
I think you sent your mind straight semesters though.
[inaudible] jumped into the waters of my space.
How could you find this message?
I liked the vaporizer.
I just thought the world was a little too slow.
You know,
I smoked 50 fucking Bong.
Jesus Christ vaporized weed is something so different to me.
I can't smoke a lot of it.
I,
every time I get,
I do too many vaporizer heads.
I'm not comfortable.
I don't like it.
What happens to you?
Got To fucking spacey.
Good.
Fuck it.
I'm gonna smoke that whole battery.
I can't keep up with the thoughts.
It's like they're coming too fast.
So it's like,
I need no,
no,
no.
I like them around mid level,
mid stream so that I can still think can,
it's when I get super,
super,
super high.
Sometimes it's like it takes me an hour before I can enjoy it because for the,
for the first hour I'm just like,
Ooh.
It's just,
it's,
it's just moving along too fast.
It's like there's a river of fish swimming by me and they're all little and I'm
trying to grab handfuls of them.
I can't get one of them.
I got the super off flying all the vaporize,
that motherfucker,
that debt and don't forget people.
We're going to be at the Austin.
Yeah.
Sitting next week,
Thursday,
Friday and Saturday the fourth through the sixth we're going to be ripping it
the fuck up.
That's not next week though,
right?
Yes it is.
It's fucking Halloween.
This Sunday gentlemen or fade today is Monday.
We'll go on a fucking Austin next Wednesday at six o'clock.
Motherfuckers will be that a let's Halloween next son.
Those Sunday.
Not Sunday,
Bro.
Yeah,
that's what I said to you.
Oh,
okay.
So we'll go on the following week,
which is next week,
isn't it?
Next week.
Yes,
that's what,
Oh yeah,
you're right.
It is next motherfucking week.
So good together Phil shows.
There's a couple of tickets left.
Jump on that bitch right now.
That's right.
Forget next week the fleshlight.
Don't forget beauty and the beast.
Don't forget,
I'm writing for Pro mma.com with my med Joe.
You need to do fuck all this writing.
They just need to get a camera and turn it on you and have you talk and put it
on.
But as a video blog,
you can tell about this writing nonsense.
I love,
right?
Don't worry about,
well,
I know you love writing the dude to what you've got to do with my life,
but if they really want to get the most out of this,
all you got to do is roll that number.
I always watch truck roll that up.
A cock sucker.
Don't worry about changing names.
What are you fucking border wars?
Roll that number,
bitch.
I love your name.
I want you to change and you know I love you,
right?
Red Band.
How did you become planet rock?
Was the game plan of how you came up?
Oh,
I'm mad flaming from biggie.
Mad Flavor.
You definitely came a bigger game.
He mad flame at 95 and then also Joey karate.
That's right.
Enjoy karate.
I gave myself before Tommy Karate came up with that and love.
Who's Tommy Karate?
Tommy.
Tara.
The fucking guy who was in the witness relocation plan.
Fuck
him.
What again?
What are you talking about?
Like crowd was spilt milk.
Some guide.
Tommy put Tyra look him up.
He wrote a book and he's Tommy Karate.
What is this?
Bryan?
This is Mika versus red one.
Is it good?
I don't know.
I just thought I'd play something.
Remember just going to take a chance.
I'm taking a chance.
Why would you do that?
Cause that's how it's gay as fuck.
So gay.
Ruined.
Kill it.
And let's wrap it up with that Diane Word Song.
Again,
connecting to your Internet right now.
That's why I put it.
Readiness.
I love you guys.
Thank you very much for watching the not connected to the Internet.
This is one of the best podcasts I do.
I love these fucking guys,
especially red band and Rogan.
He that I'm saying [inaudible] we enjoy the fuck out of doing it.
Thank you everybody for tuning in.
Um,
uh,
we uh,
appreciate it very much.
And,
and I again,
we'll see you next week in Austin,
Texas.
Where there for three nights,
Thursday,
Friday and Saturday ripping it up.
What does this,
Bryan,
this is Mc Chris Expansion.
Is this like caviar?
Cox
acquired taste?
Yes.
If you have to ask what it's like
Laguardo flaming sorting hat name is Neville.
I'm a rebel.
Don't worry about the techy introvert.
[inaudible] what are your thoughts on the kid?
You look up when you feel like [inaudible] Patterson had got them chocolate bar
that got every flavor made by the Bay Birdie box.
I got what you want.
I got what you need.
Have that.
Does whizzy beats of fizzy you say was the please,
um,
some of the pages that prohibit you.
Thank you very much ladies and gentlemen.
We will see you probably Thursday.
Looks like we're to do another one on Thursday.
We've been doing mostly two a week and uh,
and I,
and I appreciate the fuck out of it.
Every time I come to the shows and all the people that come up to me and tell me
that they really liked the podcast.
Well that's why we're doing it.
We're doing it for you guys.
It really means the world to us.
We enjoy the fuck out of doing it and we're going to keep doing it.
Thank you very much and we'll see you soon.
Thank you.
Bye Bye.
Big Kiss.
Love you bitches by
is
beating.
How bad's it does mold trees?
We smoke tree houses,
break breakdown bushes should issue.